being president good morning dear
members of the
European Parliament president of the
commission dear colleagues from the
commission I want to speak Spanish I
think it's going to be better for all of
us
dear members of the European Parliament
is
asked me to come to the European
Parliament this morning this morning as
president of the Foreign Affairs Council
to talk about the need for a consistent
strategy
for EU China relations ladies and
gentlemen it's always good to have a
consistent strategy
when it comes to China or anything else
it's good to have a consistent strategy
but in the light of the wording of the
title of this debate
it might be thought that the title means
that the EU doesn't have a consistent or
coherent strategy
so I think that if that's the case
I think I'm being directly mentioned and
referred to because as high
representative under the treaty my task
is to make certain that there is
consistency in coherence in the EU
foreign policy and if you don't think
that there is such a consistency then
there's going to be my fault
although not only my fault
so we're talking about foreign common
foreign and security policy
title five of the treaty in other words
a common foreign policy but not a single
foreign policy because each individual
member State
maintains its own powers when it comes
to foreign policy even though they have
committed themselves to
building a common foreign policy each
one still has their own policy at the
moment so in something as complicated as
relations with China there are obviously
different approaches
because there are different interests in
Play Between the member states
that's just a fact
but if we want to build a coherent EU
China strategy
it's vital that each and every one of
the
stakeholders in the EU acts while fully
respecting the treaties
exercising their powers and cap playing
their various roles each one has their
own task and that affects all of the
member states the council the the
accounts the European Council the
commission and of course the honorable
members of the European Parliament so
as you know and as the payet report
sensibly points out that common foreign
and security policy
and as part of that relations with China
is defined unanimously by the European
Council and by Council the European
Council defines the Strategic interests
of the EU
it sets goals
and defines the general guidelines for
foreign policy
and basing itself on that my Council the
Foreign Affairs Council draws up the
cfsp
and adopts the relevant decisions to
apply it
the commission
which is my honor to be a vice president
of also plays a crucial role when it
comes to areas which have a huge impact
on our foreign relations
and
since we're talking more and more about
Economic Security
as the president has mentioned as part
of National Security
this is an Everly ever
increasingly important roles this
content of Economic Security is going to
have a crucial
wait when it comes to our very
understanding of
foreign policy
Japan and the United States are
including this in their own definition
of foreign policy and we need to do the
same thing bearing in mind the
institutional characteristics of the
union and the fact that it's
ultimately the member states who have
the requisite
instruments to apply this Economic
Security through restrictions or
controls on exports and Investments both
within and out with Europe
as you'll be aware we do have a strategy
on China dating back to 2019 the famous
triptych and there's no question that a
lot of things have happened since then
and we need to recalibrate the strategy
so that it's in line with the new
circumstances but the EU has never
explicitly defined China as a direct
threat to our security
as it had done with Russia
on the 22nd in Versailles so this
triptych approach this multi
focal approach has shown its worth when
it comes to China but recently uh
relations have worsened as you'll be
aware because of what's happened the
sanctions imposed by China against
members of this house the economic
difficulties with Lithuania and the
exercises in the Gulf of Thai was Strait
of Taiwan
so when it comes to revising our
relations with China the
the
resolution approved by this house Ms
vonder Lion's speech the in the light of
the measures now also by the United
States on export controls on investment
in China and semiconductor exports as a
mark as a part of the framework of
National Security you'd also be aware of
the
foreign
government from the member states and
the
prisoners of the commission I myself
mentioned in March the urgent need that
the next Council
would be
devoted to China and
the leaders met in the European Council
should decide to revise this China
strategy and given that as high
representative of the EU under the
treaty it's my task to contribute to the
drafting of this strategy let me tell
you how I personally
I'm not speaking on behalf of the
council yet but let me tell you how I
see our relations with China and how our
strategy can be and ought to be adapted
we're very focused of course on the
Russian aggression against Ukraine
and
there's another political problem of
course which is
also large which is China but China is
not Russia China is a super power
a superpower which is growing it's
present throughout the world its
influence is considerable it's political
weight is continuing to grow and its
attractiveness to many countries in the
South can't be denied
for example in asean
China has become the biggest investor
it's overtaken us
it's as if China has started a process
what it looks at and tries to preempt
the impact of various sanctions it's
what we call de-risking
that's what they seem to be doing
we need to Bear these issues in mind
as we try to define a consistent
strategy when it comes to China
but
although
there is the fact that we are in rival
mode we have to keep talking to China we
can't
stop negotiating with China when it
comes to trying to sort out the biggest
problems in the world because China's
not a democracy there's more than
40 highly indebted countries for example
there's the thousands of millions of
people affected by climate change things
like this mean that we have to work
together
China's got more coal than the rest of
the world put together and it's the
biggest creditor for emerging countries
so from a debt and from a climate
perspective there's no way of solving
those problems unless China is involved
and working with us
we need to keep talking to China just
because of its massive influence in the
world and because dialogue is the basis
of international policy
until has happened between Russia and
Ukraine the inevitable happens China is
emerging has emerged and it's going to
continue to be a player
and in a few years China and India will
represent almost the half
of world production
and they'll be back in fact in the place
that they used to occupy before the
Industrial Revolution the wheel of
History would have turned full circle
but it's important that we look in a
clear effective way at this is clear
that we need to align our positions we
can't speak with just one voice because
of the multiplicity of voices that we
have but at least we could be a
well-tuned chorus many voices Associated
trying to say the same thing
or at least they're on the same
wavelength
plurality doesn't have to be a problem
if we have an agreed position
in particular an agreed position on two
issues
is Europe a pole in a multi-polar world
does it have its own existence as a
political entity
what we call Strategic autonomy or just
autonomy in Europe
and secondly
what's going to be our attitude to
China's view of Russia's aggression in
Ukraine when Mr macron went to China and
talked to president Chi and said that
I hope you can talk some sense into
Putin and it's possible that President
Sheen didn't think that Putin
needed since being talked into his
possible president Lula was in
China a couple of days ago and he
basically expressed Unity with China's
strategic goals I
prepared a long speech I was going to
deliver in China which uh was canceled
because I got covered but
I still think we can boil it down to
four words values
Economic Security Taiwan and Ukraine
first of all values
we don't have
the same vision
of Human Rights and respect for
fundamental rights as individual of
individuals that China does and in all
International forum and with all
countries in the world China's
developing a narrative which
subordinates fundamental political
rights to Economic Development
when I was young
we used to talk about
real freedoms and formal freedoms the
real ones
are those that are linked with your
material living conditions but I don't
think it's one or the other it's not
either or we need them both
we need freedom to be free
but we need
this political freedom to be a motor
to generate wealth for our citizens we
want freedom and we want economic
progress and we need to
defend that position and
counteract China's narrative with all of
the intellectual Force at our disposal
but we need to continue with that
dialogue and we've started doing that
bilaterally after China
broke off the dialogue on human rights
with us secondly economic
relations and Economic Security
uh economic relations are highly
unbalanced terribly unbalanced
the trade deficit is huge and it
continues to grow
400 billion
indefisive
and they've got a surplus of 400 and
70 is no longer a supplier of cheap
Goods produced through cheap labor quite
the contrary
it's now at The Cutting Edge of
technological development and it's a
competitor when it comes to the most
sophisticated Goods
ultimately
cheap stuff ends up costing you a lot of
money that's what my grandmother always
used to say
and we learned that with Russia and now
we're learning it in economic
competition with China
not because we're uncompetitive but
because China
isn't run by the market it's run by the
state and that's changed the ground
rules very considerably we do have
problems of ground rules with the United
States of course we compete with the us
and we talk about the competition rules
with them but at the end of the day
we're talking about two market economies
in China's something different uh
relations are unbalanced
because we also depend on certain
producers make us vulnerable and this
vulnerability is increasing when these
products these Commodities are
integrated into production processes
that end in fine in Goods which we
import from China that's important
therefore that de-risking as the
commission president mentioned
and that can be done by looking for
different sources of Supply
re-jigging the supply chains controlling
in and out Investments
but always respecting the rules of the
WTO it would be
weird if we talked about obeying the
rules and we then voted the rules of the
body that's given most in terms of
setting out of fair playing field
in terms of trade de-risking it's a
horrible word in Spanish reducing the
risks means that because there are risks
to be reduced and if we redirect our
economic flows and move to countries in
Asia other countries than China then
almost automatically these countries
will
beef up their relations with China their
trade relations because they'll be
importing the raw materials they need to
produce the goods that they're going to
then sell to us so we will only have
placed a middleman as far as our
independence dependence is concerned
will be
indirectly dependent and that could
actually be worse in the situation we're
in at the moment because these countries
are far more vulnerable to Chinese
pressure
than we are now
we need to reject the illusion that to
protect ourselves economically from
China
we need to undermine our economies are
depends on International Trade is too
great
it's more than twice that of the United
States we wouldn't gain anything in
terms of security and we would
weaken our economic position as an
economic counterweight we need to
diversify to reduce vulnerability but
reducing vulnerability at the end of the
day is the same as increasing autonomy
do you risk and strategically go
together
because
dependence is the opposite of autonomy
so the more autonomous you are the less
dependent You Are by definition
and if
Eco Independence is bad then the policy
is bad as well if these things aren't
balanced one side's much stronger than
the other that's not an alliance
I won't say what the name of it is but
it's you all know
if you're not autonomous you're
dependent we need to reduce risk
but that shouldn't just be a slogan
ladies and gentlemen it's not just
a nice phrase it's got to be a long-term
policy we took years to put it together
in the same way that we'll spend we
spent a long time increasing our
military capacity and we need to keep
doing that the biggest geopolitical risk
is that de-risking with China should
increase
China's ability to have an impact on the
rest of Asia
so that's something we need to look at
together all institutions I mean all
member states
in a way that relevant this ongoing and
is committed to finding a solution on
Taiwan now
Taiwan is crucial for Europe
for three reasons
it's the most strategic straight in the
world particularly as far as trade is
concerned we need to be present there
through the freedom of navigation
operations and our fleets need to be
there
secondly
not just for moral ethical reasons
that we should reject any external
interference in the Affairs of Taiwan
also it'll be very serious for us
economically because taiwan's
role in the production of the most
important semi most advanced
semiconductors is crucial so if we
really want to be a geopolitical player
we need to be present throughout the
world
to reaffirm our positions to defend our
interests to call for calm to face down
provocations no matter where they come
from that's why the best way is to go
back to the status quo anti Taiwan is
clearly part of our geostrategic
perimeter to guarantee peace
to defend our interest without throwing
oil on the fire are all states in Europe
I'm sure would agree with that view
when it comes to Ukraine everyone knows
what we think our message that China is
quite clear the president made it very
clear when she was there
we all have our relations with China
can't develop normally if China doesn't
use its influence with Russia
to get it to withdraw its troops from
Ukraine and put an end to this war
in the light of a conflict which affects
the territory integrity and the
sovereignty of an independent state
whose borders are protected by
international law and the commitments of
the major Powers including Russia and
China
any neutrality
which doesn't do a distinction between
the aggressor and the country aggressed
is basically on the side of the
aggressor we've said this very often and
we're going to continue to say it
finally
from a geopolitical standpoint
we need to avoid a new cold war between
the west and the Far East
as opposed to the east that the previous
Cold War was about and we've got a lot
of difficulties in countries in the
South which need to be born in mind here
because look at the Strategic triangle
Europe China us to see it from that
standpoint only would be reductionist
and reductive because it doesn't bear in
mind the existence of the great masses
of people in the south
where China is paying special attention
because it's trying to build a new world
order through them different from
the one that they would say that the
West has built and they're quite open in
saying this
they don't mince words when they're
we know that's a situation that's why
the debate on China is only just
starting it needs to be done in a calm
way in a realistic way we need to be
aware that things are what they are and
the numbers the figures are what they
are we need to be determined we need to
be clear and we need to be more united
than ever that Unity is vitally
important even though it doesn't rule
out having different voices speaking on
behalf of Europe just as we're going to
see today win the council and the
commission thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr Burrell now on
behalf of the commission the president
miss funderline
Mr President
Minister Joseph honorable members
during my trip to China this month
I was fortunate to be in Beijing on the
day of the Ching Ming Festival one of
the most traditional Chinese holidays
it is a day to honor
and pay respect to past Generations
and it is part of the very rich history
and culture of China that certainly
fascinates and captures the imagination
of people all around the world
seeing this country again firsthand
only reinforced my deep admiration and
respect for the people of China
for centuries they have helped shape
World Civilization and in the last
decades they have really transformed the
economy of their country lifting more
than 800 million people out of poverty
in the last 45 years
we should never lose sight of the
magnitude of this transformation into a
modern day economic Powerhouse
key Global player
and the leader in many of the
cutting-edge technologies that certainly
will shape the next Decades of global
civilization and progress
this International and economic status
as well as our own interests make it all
the more important for Europe to manage
its relations with China
and for me that also shows that
decoupling
is clearly not viable
desirable or even practical for Europe
but as I said back in January and as I
set out in more detail a few weeks ago
there is clearly a need for Europe
to work on de-risking some important and
sensitive parts of our relationship so
de-risking but not decoupling
much has been said about this since I
set out the principles of this debrising
strategy and even more has been said
since the last trip
in many ways that reaction is good
because Europe needs to have this
discussion and so I want first and
foremost thank the parliament for
putting this debate on today it's urgent
that it's good that we have this debate
most importantly
I say this because this relationship is
too important for us not to Define our
own European strategy and principles for
engagement with China
I believe we can
and we must
carve out our own distinct European
approach
that also leaves space for us to
cooperate with other partners too
and the starting point for this
is the need to have a shared and very
clear eyed picture of the risks and the
opportunities in our engagement with
China
and this means
acknowledging
as well as clearly saying
that the Chinese Communist party's
actions
have now caught up with its stated
Ambitions and the hardening of China's
overall strategic posture over the last
years
for example
the shows of military force in the South
China South China Sea in the East China
Sea and at the border with India
directly affect our partners and their
legitimate interests
or on the issue of Taiwan
the eu's one China policy
is long-standing
we have consistently called for peace
and stability in the Taiwan Strait
and we stand strongly against any
unilateral change of the state of school
in particular by the use of force
[Applause]
we must also never shy away
from talking about the deeply concerning
and Grave human rights violations in
qingyang
and just as China has been ranking up
its military posture it has also ramped
up its policy of Economic and trade
coercion as we've seen from Lithuania to
Australia
and the targeting of everything from pop
bands to trade brands
we have also seen these tactics directed
right here in the house of European
democracy
and I want to express my solidarity to
those members of the European Parliament
who have been unfairly sanctioned by the
Chinese Communist party just for calling
out human rights violations
and all this is symptomatic for the fact
that China has now turned the page
on the era of reform and opening
and is moving into a new era of security
and control
I heard this in Beijing from many
European companies
who have witnessed firsthand this shift
towards security and away from the logic
of open markets and free trade
and to strengthen that security and
control Leverage
China is openly pursuing a policy of
reducing its dependency on the world
that's completely okay that's their
right but while increasing the world's
dependency on itself
you know the examples for example
whether it's on critical raw materials
or the renewable energy on emerging
tech-like artificial intelligence
Quantum Computing or biotech
honorable members
having this clear-eyed assessment
of the Chinese Communist parties actions
and direction of travel
actually including its relations with
Putin's Russia and its attitude towards
the war in Ukraine
is a prerequisite
for today's discussion
and it will allow us to develop an
approach that is tailored to our
economic and National Security
imperatives
one that we all can rally around
and one that is clearly understood
in Europe
in the world
and crucially also in China itself
and this last point is one of the key
reasons
I felt it was important to make the trip
to Beijing alongside president macron
it was a chance to discuss with
President XI
the shared challenges that we need to
work on together
whether in our bilateral trading
relation
or on global issues like debt relief
climate change and nuclear
non-proliferation
but equally important the trip was
necessary
to ensure that we are as honest and
clear in our messaging in Beijing
as we are in Brussels or here in
strasbok
this is a core part of our efforts to
de-risk through diplomacy
by reducing the space for
misunderstanding and miscommunication
regardless of how difficult the
conversations may be
the point I made in Beijing is
that we do not want to cut economic
societal political and scientific ties
we have many strong links and shine as a
vital trading partner
our trade represents
represents some 2.3 billion euros a day
most of our trade and goods and services
remains mutually beneficial but there is
an urgent need to rebalance our
relationship
on the basis of transparency
predictability and reciprocity
what we want is
China to respect the Level Playing Field
when it comes to access for our
companies to the Chinese market
to respect transparency about subsidies
to respect the intellectual property
and Beyond this we also know that there
are some areas where trade and
investment poses risks to our economic
and National Security
particularly in the context of China's
explicit Fusion of its Military and
Commercial sectors
and this is why
the central part of our future China
strategy must be economic de-risking
there are four areas for us to work on
which I want very briefly to touch on
the first is taking a critical look at
our own resilience and dependency and
making our own economy and Industry more
competitive and more resilient
and this is the work we have been doing
together you know it it began in the
investment in the green and the digital
through next Generation EU
to the pillars of our industrial policy
and the landmarked acts you know too
it's the chips act it is the critical
raw materials act and it's the Net Zero
industry Act
and leader signed up to it in Versailles
during the French presidency so now we
must keep strengthening our resilience
and sovereignty
in key areas you know them all it's
energy it's health and pharmaceutical
products it's food security but also of
course when it comes to our defense
capabilities
the second point is becoming Bolder and
better in using our existing trade
defense instruments
we have given ourselves the right tools
to deal with security concern and
economic distortions
so we must be more assertive
in using them when we need them
and I want to take this opportunity to
thank the parliament for its leadership
and agreeing on the new anti-coercion
instrument just a few weeks ago
the third element is the lead to look at
where we need to work on new tools
for some critical sectors
we need to ensure that our company's
capital
the expertise their knowledge
are not used to enhance the military and
intelligence capabilities of those
who also are our systemic Rivals that
cannot be
[Applause]
so we have to look at where there are
gaps in our toolbox
which allow the leakage of emerging and
sensitive Technologies through
investments in other countries
and this is why we're currently
reflecting on if
and how Europe should develop an
instrument on outbound investment for
very small number but very sensitive
Technologies
this will form part of a New Economic
Security strategy which the commission
will put forward in the coming months
the fourth principle is cooperation with
partners
with an economic security on trade
whether with Partners we are close to in
the G7 or with those with whom we have
loser ties but some shared interests
this will be a core part of
diversification and the strengthening of
the resilience of our supply chains to
reduce our own vulnerabilities
honorable members
as the high representative said in 2019
the commission and the eeas collectively
proposed a strategic update of our China
policy
since then the world has changed
enormously
China has changed Europe has changed
and that's why our European strategy has
to adapt to
a few weeks ago when I gave my speech on
China
I said
a strong European China policy relies on
strong coordination between member
states and EU institutions
and on the willingness
to avoid a divide and conquer tactics
that we know we may face
we have already in the recent days and
weeks seen those tactics in action
and it is now time for Europe to move to
action two now is the time to
demonstrate our Collective will
it is time to jointly Define what
success looks like and to show that
Unity that makes us so strong and in
this sense I say long live Europe thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much president from the
line now Mr Vapor please
president
president of the commission
High representative
the way that we deal with China is the
central political issue of this decade
of the century
and by way of preparation I came across
a quote from Napoleon let China sleep
because when it wakes it will shake the
Earth
it's obvious that China is no longer
asleep China is waking up it's rousing
over the past decades in economic terms
it's tried to wake up but its economic
growth is not sufficient for it it wants
political influence since well it is
claiming political power across the
world
so it's good that today we are
discussing this topic as a prominent one
and I think we need to give a vote of
thanks to our president of the
commission responderline has made a very
clear message on our behalf we need to
respect China as an important country in
the world but secondly there's a
partnership where it is in our mutual
interests third we need to work together
to stop Putin and that is a question on
which we're going to test it
China fourthly a strong partnership with
their American partners
defending our interests together with
the USA against China that's why I'd
like to thank Miss Wonderland as the Epp
this has died in the mall Epp issue
Emmanuel macons also shown a great deal
of
positive action here we saw that when Mr
Macon left China there was a military
exercise with all sorts of ships and
um
missiles
that were meant to simulate encircling
Taiwan and this Taiwan question is not
an abstract problem it constitutes the
fate of millions of people China doesn't
decide over the future of Taiwan
Taiwan decides over the future of Taiwan
and in this military
atmosphere Macon said Europe cannot
be drawn into the conflict between China
and Taiwan well I have to say I was a
bit shocked by this quite because Taiwan
is important in terms of economic
terms 90 of our high quality semi
conductors are produced in Taiwan and
Taiwan in this region stands for freedom
of democracy if you're going to attack
Taiwan you're destroying you want to
destroy democracy as we have seen in
happening in Hong Kong it's naive to say
that Taiwan is not something that
concerns us obviously Europe has to act
on its own behalf it has to find its own
way we shouldn't just swallow anything
that's been spoon fed from the US that's
not a question but when it comes to
Taiwan it's a question of Defending
economic interests and it's also a
question of our values if you're not
clear on this point
then you're betraying the European
interests and European values
perhaps the French President should also
beg the question of who was applauding
recently podemos Valencia Putin Le Pen
these were people who were very positive
to what he said the rest of the western
world was at least silent
the populists want to fight Macar and I
think Mr McCall is a convinced European
and
the European Unity is something close to
his heart but with his uh his speeches
unfortunately he's sharing the opposite
the unity of Europe has been damaged
considerably Macar has failed to provide
the necessary support to Taiwan and
support transatlantic
alliances and we see that there the
questions of things being sold to
Taiwanese firms and I understand where
people see that the US is defending a
certain interests better than we are
we shouldn't be surprised if Washington
starts asking whether
Ukraine is a European
issue why should American taxpayers do
so much to defend Ukraine
and freedom in Ukraine when the Epp
consider that it is a transatlantic task
to act on behalf of democracy and
freedom and a close cooperation with the
US is essential
and the this state visit uh to China
showed the
um certain state of affairs with Miss
vondeline going to China and my car as
well but Macau managed to destroy a
degree of European Corporation where
Miss funderline was building it so
before the next Summit we need Clarity
from heads of state and government let's
see a case of coherent plan from all
member states of the European Union
trans Atlantic support
uh secondly we need to see more trade we
need to finish macrosore we need to
establish that and make a stronger
partnership with South America thirdly
European technological leadership and
sovereignty needs to be established when
it comes to critical infrastructure most
notably fourthly a European Defense
pillar that complements what NATO is
doing
we're
naked at the moment in the world and
from that front and fifthly and finally
the founding fathers of the EU started
with the coal and steel Union Our
Generation today needs to complete that
idea and look at the resource and energy
Union being established and completed so
we can be independent we know what needs
to be done the heads of state and
government just need the courage to act
let's stop being naive
on transatlantic cooperation let's stop
all of these ego trips of our heads of
Satan government and let's say yes to a
common defense of the European way of
life thank you
thank you Mr Weber
we now have Mrs Garcia Perez please
thank you Mr President
humanity is faced with unprecedented
Global challenges the climate emergency
pandemic and war in Europe
in this context The Diplomatic offensive
of various European leaders in Beijing
is crucial for preventing further
escalation of polarization and tension
in the world in the debate in our
relations with China it's not good to
enter into a kind of block type thinking
we need to define a position on China
That's based on open strategic autonomy
and guarantees technological and trade
which is safe and while firmly defending
International cooperation and
multilateralism and we need therefore
for that a China starchy which is
consistent effective
grounded and more unified than ever we
need therefore to somewhat out and re
reverse the direction that relations
between China and the union are going
through at the moment we can't simply
be confrontational we need to base our
relations on reciprocity transparency
and respect for international law
economically it means leveling the
playing field and guaranteeing full
reciprocity between the two sides we
need a stable regulatory framework
which opens the East without closing off
the West when it comes to Ukraine China
and the EU need to look for an exit
strategy which will end the war which
isn't just causing inculcatable human
tragedy but it's also a threat for our
interests and the interest of the
charter of the principles of the charter
of the United Nations Xi Jinping is a
traditional defender of sovereignty and
territorial integrity and is against the
use of nuclear weapons and he needs
therefore to listen to what he said
himself and put pressure on those who
violate those principles in a
threatening such an attack Putin's
Russia as a permanent member of the
security Council she needs to meet
wizardensky to talk about a fair piece
based on the withdrawal of Russian
troops from the Ukrainian territory
shouldn't forget that China regards
Putin as an indispensable
Ally for a search in a search for a new
international order we need therefore to
strengthen dialogue to reduce risks and
cooperate where it's possible there are
certain red lines which we can't go past
the delivery of arms to Russia and
changing the Status Quo in Taiwan by
forces unacceptable the absence of
effective results or immediate results
after the visits of the European leaders
shouldn't stop Mr Burrell operating as
far as China is concerned the
possibilities of cooperation are
enormous we need to increase
multilateral industrialism as a
framework to deal with global challenges
we need to strengthen the fight against
climate change under the Paris agreement
we should remember that human rights are
Universal need to be respected
everywhere in xinjiang and Hong Kong our
message to China needs to be clear
maintaining sanctions against members of
this house will make it impossible for
us to build trust the time has come for
China to lift the sanctions against
members of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen our strategy to
China needs determination realism and
more European Union than ever let's
me finish
by giving Mr Weber a bit of advice
you've now got a new role leader of the
opposition
you're happy to criticize All European
leaders one day you're criticizing
macron next it's Mr Schultz and the only
people you don't ever criticize are the
leaders of the extreme right be careful
because one day you might make a mistake
and criticize misunderline as well
thank you president
of the commission
High representative minister
let me
perhaps begin
by uh
continuing on from what uh the president
the Socialists said let me react Mr
Weber to your speech it really focus
more on Mr macron than uh China
I mean we did change the title
a little bit but uh let me recall that
what we're talking about is not internal
matters but I would also say that uh I
can't don't take lessons from a
political party which for the last year
has increased our European dependency in
terms of energy
diplomacy economically
everywhere together with the members of
your respective governments you've
systematically done that this one plus
system was pretty interesting wasn't it
because we method for the method
we constantly sold off our
infrastructure to the Chinese our ports
and our airports and it was Epp
governments who were in charge at the
time so what's the problem when the
president of the French Republic makes
certain statements I mean when he says
we need more European Independence
what's the problem there
okay
well having said that let me now
move on to the speeches given by the
high representative and the president I
think they show that there is a
consensus
when it comes to seeing China as a
partner as a competitor but also as a
systemic rival and I think it's all
three things at once
and uh we need to see them as that but
we need to take our interests into
account here and I'd I welcome the work
of the president of the commission the
high representative and also the
president of the council because I think
there is a line that needs to
underpin uh economic relations and our
values vis-a-vis China I mean we need a
global order that's based on
international law democratic values and
human rights
here I fully agree with my colleagues
the United States are an important Ally
in the stability of the indo-pacific
region
taiwan's security depends on that
and also elsewhere and that's why we're
developing our cooperation with type one
but uh it's also because of our values
that this Parliament can't consider any
new agreement with China while some of
our colleagues are under sanctions and
while the uyghurs are being persecuted
both things are important both of them
our second interest relates to Fair
reciprocal trading relations
international trade
needs to be the basis of our prosperity
but it does create dependencies which go
against our
sovereignty
we can't move from one dependency to
another here we can't simply
undertake knee-jerk reactions
and uh
move fully away from Trading relations
which is a little bit the U.S strategy
at the moment which is of concern as
well so I think what the commission's
proposing on this is a good step forward
on raw materials developing green
Industries
there'll be new mechanisms
to fight uh Chinese unfair competition
so
let me conclude there president by
talking about the obstacles that we face
in coming up with a consistent strategy
on our relations I mean I listen to
heads of state and government I listen
to our institutional representatives and
I don't see them being naive
I don't see the same level of naivete as
I saw 10 or 15 years ago and I also
don't see anti-china policies
I am however surprised when I hear from
elected representatives in this house
that uh
there we need to base ourselves on uh on
people when I hear from people who are
afraid of European Independence and
Power
I think if we're going to be considered
an appropriate Power by the Chinese we
need to get organized and act on the
basis of European interests and European
interests alone thank you
thank you very much Mr Sergio now Mr
Lombards please
thank you president in French
well there you go
colleagues that is the word that really
characterizes the attitude of the
European Union for 40 years in China
mercantilist naivety where
people think that opening up completely
our markets to unfettered axis would
allow us to have access to the market
Chinese market to democratic naivety
thinking that soft trade would help
bring the Beijing regime to Liberal
democracy and narcissistic naivety where
people thought the trauma fences of
heads of state and government from
Europe could change the Chinese approach
so we've seen this naivety in Europe
that has led to a lot of cost having to
be paid by Future Industries for example
such as the photovoltaic panels but many
firms have been prevented from accessing
the Chinese market unless they agree to
transferring their technology
now I've seen these charm offenses but
nevertheless the Chinese regime is
moving more and more to internal
authoritarianism and towards the outside
world they're trying to take over and
carry out this anti-west propaganda
so it's time the European Union wake up
and move away from this trip called
naivety and decide what we should be
doing with China rather than how we
would like it to be
let us move to the adult stage of real
politique first and foremost Europe has
to reduce its over dependence on China
to have a better
economic autonomy it's not a question of
breaking our links with China it will
remain a trade partner and a
somebody who we need to work with to
deal with the challenges of the 21st
century such as
environmental disaster but the European
Union has to bolster its own capacities
there secondly we can't continue to have
our eyes closed towards the geopolitical
Ambitions of Beijing
where it wants this multi-polar setup it
wants to develop a Chinese hegemony in
the 21st century and here we'll only be
respected if we can meet two conditions
first of all if we manage to stand
shoulder to shoulder and show no
ambiguity to any attack by China on
democratic values or human rights
whether it be within its borders like
xinjiang Hong Kong or in the rest of the
world it's obvious to us that only in a
negotiated process can be what we have
when it comes to Taiwan secondly we have
to put a stop to the double standards
policies that really confused our
International policies in the EU
there are many
um member states who were against the
illegal
invasion of Iraq in 2003 by the U.S and
others and that is cost us then and is
still costing us if we want us to have a
word that is considered a bond in the
world then we have to do our homework
there
and this is something that the German
foreign minister said annelina belbach
when she went to China recently she said
that
we have seen in the same way that you
did Madam president from the line on the
30th of March
rest assured that our group will support
you and your ambition to make the
European Union a geopolitical actor
that's respectable and respected thank
you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Lambert's now Mr Bourgeois
please
thank you very much president
let China sleep because if China awakes
the Earth will shake
that was a warning that Napoleon came
with 200 years ago
well today China is a giant in economic
and military terms also China is a a
very good strategist which is asserting
itself around the world decoupling from
China is not a good response the EU has
to continue to engage in multilateralism
has to continue along the trade line
and moreover our transition to renewable
energy will collapse like a souffle
if we don't have those rare Earths where
China has made itself in strategic terms
as good as essential
s but we will have to de-risk we're
going to have to reduce the risks that
are there through having a smart and
open strategic autonomy through being
quicker in concluding our trade
agreements and diversifying our supply
chains by not leaving our critical
infrastructure and strategic Investments
to China in a naive fashion
and it would be malicious to allow the
impression to be given that Taiwan is
the concern only of China and the us
because then we'll just be standing
alone in our support of Ukraine
we cannot allow our transatlantic
partnership to have a wedge driven
through it my group is calling on a show
of unity in our policy vis-a-vis China
thank you Mr bourgeois
Mr zani now please
colleagues
I think that what's happened recently
the journeys to China last week
confirmed two principles first of all
that
we don't have a geopolitical
dimension in the European Union
that's something which the commission
said in 2019 and it's still true today
secondly
that was the thing that was confirmed
month by month
is that
macron is
a huge problem for Europe because all
the comments made in about
China
hid the fact from people that he
actually ended up coming back home after
going to China with a lot of very fat
contracts that have been signed so whose
interest was he serving really now it's
true that autonomy is an important issue
as far as Europe is concerned but I
think that there are certain arguments
where there shouldn't be any ambiguity
where the concept of strategic autonomy
is sometimes inconsistent and one of
those is China we can't have strategic
autonomy you've got credible allies with
whom one walks together and needs we
need to work together with them to meet
Global challenges and there are
autocratic regimes like Russia and China
from whom we should distance ourselves
there's no third way here Europe needs
to decide with whom it's going to line
up I don't think there are any doubts
that Europe should
work with it Western allies China is the
biggest geopolitical challenge which the
West has to face and we can't think
about
meeting that challenge while distancing
ourselves from people who have the same
views that we have and have demonstrated
they have those values which we talk up
here every single day
having said that Europe needs to
understand
how it should approach China
and what we're doing what we've have
been doing since 2019 isn't the way to
do it President Van Der Lyon reminded us
of certain measures that the commission
put forward that we're working on to
update things and bring about this
de-risking which the high representative
talked about when it comes to China but
Madam president these are far from being
enough the chips Act
The Net Zero industry Act
the critical raw materials Act
these are all pieces of legislation
which won't really allow us to decouple
ourselves from China to become
independent of China and the final point
I agree with many of the comments that
you made Madam president and you made Mr
Hive representative but
the thing is that
you don't actually follow up on the
things that you say the Deeds are very
different from the words if we look at
the figures EU dependence on China in
the last few years and thanks partly to
the green transition has dramatically
increased we're risking
to make another huge error that's to say
deliver ourselves bound hand and foot to
an autocratic dictatorship so let me end
with a question
which
I either won't be answered or the answer
I won't like the answer what's gonna the
EU going to do if China decides to
invade Taiwan we need to think about
that we need to think about what
instruments we have at our disposal to
stop making the same blunders that we
made in the past that we're still paying
for today
good
president
thank you president president
colleagues from the council
colleagues now the debate around uh
macron's trip to China raises a
fundamental issue here in uh Parliament
what is Europe's place in the global
geopolitical
situation and let me Begin by saying
that the French President made two
errors the first
would be to compare China and the United
States in the same manner at the same
time as Taiwan is undergoing another uh
uh
intimidation exercise and the second is
to ignore the uyghurs
now this is a an important debate on a
concept that we've been defending for a
long time non-alignment now I want to be
clear here because
people often get upset when I say that
but non-alignment doesn't mean
neutrality we clearly need to support
people who are under attack for example
Ukraine and it also means supporting all
those who suffer and are oppressed
across the world Europe also needs to
defend the current precarious status quo
in Taiwan and avoid escalation but we
also need to take a position on a
case-by-case basis and the only basis
for our positions should be
international law
we're still very far from that today and
the major speeches that macron makes
which are spoken and forgotten about
almost immediately never produce any
major facts I mean Europe will continue
to exist but it won't be independent
while its defense is guaranteed by NATO
we shouldn't Simply Be subservient to
the United States we should be talking
directly to countries of the South
independent Europe will
not exist until we put human rights
before the prophets of multinationals
and uh if we continue to sign up to free
trade agreements which increase our
dependencies I actually agree with one
of my previous colleagues uh yes Mr
Weber it's you who systematically
insured our International dependence and
Mr seizure your call for strategic
autonomy would be touching if it wasn't
for the fact that your group has
systematically supported free trade
agreements that weaken us weaken our
industry and make it make it impossible
for us to produce the medicines that we
need in Europe first and foremost
paracetamol I think what we've learned
from what happened last week is that uh
basically what we're doing just reduces
our credibility on the international
stage
if Europe wants to have some weight in
the world it genuinely needs to be
non-aligned thank you
thank you very much Miss Opry now Mr
Castello
thank you chair Madam president I
representative dear colleagues it is
certainly true that we are obligated to
purchase selective engagement with
Beijing that are multilateral by Nature
most notably the fight against climate
change but we cannot Overlook those
unacceptable behaviors that the Chinese
government refuses to live apart several
colleagues in this room are still under
Section sanctions and last Friday we
have seen the unbelievable arrests of
Human Rights activists that they were
going to a meeting with our delegation
in Beijing furthermore the so-called
military exercises near Taiwan are
dangerously similar to a full-fledged
Invasion and China's neutrality
regarding the Russian invasion of
Ukraine is quoting our high
representative simply just not credible
in diplomacy and in geopolitics it takes
you to tango nothing more than a mere
selective engagement on certain issues
can be accepted before we will see a
real and effective actions from our
Chinese counterparts in those fields
that are not only essential to us but
Universal by definition such as human
rights let's keep the channel for
dialogue open but without being naive
therefore protecting our strategic
infrastructure and our European
technological Serenity and upon all
let's always speak with one single voice
to defend our red lines for real thank
you
thank you very much Mr castaldo now for
one and a half minutes Miss Yuki Phoenix
dear colleagues although we are late we
are finally getting to the point
the pandemic has spoken Europe up and
the Russian war has opened our eyes we
need for a strategy towards China
the right strategy requires the right
assessment of the situation and we got
it from both key speakers today thank
you
Russia and China have the same goal to
destroy the development of the
democratic world because democracy is a
threat to both regimes
China's aims are even greater to take
over as much of the world as possible
hence the key principle of our strategy
is the unity of democracies we cannot
repeat the same mistakes I hope that we
have learned the lessons from the
dependence on Russia
today when we speak about security we
need to talk not about autonomy from the
US but about the common strategy for
democracies and how to overcome
autocracies and dictatorships and Mr
Weber is Right Taiwan is not just a U.S
interest president macron this part of
Chinese people like Hong Kong as well
has proved that democracy is not a
foreign idea to the Chinese
China seeks to divide us the most
striking example is the former 17 plus
China and CE Corporation format
the first step of the common strategy
could be abandoning this format I call
for a long-term strategy towards Russia
and China that is not aimed at momentary
benefits but focuses on sustainable
peace and security on the European
continent
the Frog
thank you very much Miss sukovicenya now
for two minutes Mr Machias
thank you very much president president
of the commission High representative
colleagues in 2019 the European Council
adopted an EU position on China
identifying it simultaneously as we've
heard as a
partner as a competitor and a systemic
rival
this was you won't be surprised to hear
put forward by the then High
representative vice president something
a position in which since the Treaty of
Lisbon has represented both commission
and Council in European Union foreign
policy trying to unify our position
since then we've been through events
that none of us could have predicted the
pandemic the crisis it led to and in
particular
The
Diplomatic problems the mass diplomacy
and vaccine diplomacy uh Global crisis
caused by that and then of course the
board of aggression of Russia against
Ukraine with the political and economic
sanctions
that's why it's important that as the
higher Representatives said we need to
reassess our 2019 position without
necessarily jeopardizing it looking at
China as a strategic rival we need to
eliminate our dependency in various
critical areas when it comes to raw
material but
we need to look at issues like
semiconductors not because we want to
break off relations who don't want to be
in trouble as far as our relations are
concerned particularly when it comes to
our values as a competitor we need to
position ourselves in the front line of
technological development so that we
don't lag behind in the future sectors
Burrell was saying we need to use the
political foreign policy instruments
that we have that were mentioned by the
lion thank you for doing that but also
it's vital that now we stretch out a
hand to Latin America we've got a chance
to deal with that and China is trying to
supplant us there as well but we also
need to remain partners with China in
certain areas which we can only deal
with together particularly when it comes
to climate change
or working together to put an end to the
barbaric invasion of Ukraine thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Marcus now for two minutes
thank you president
Mr Burrell ladies and gentlemen
recent weeks have not shown a single or
United Europe
for years now Kissinger said who should
I call if I want to speak to Europe
and now citizens and probably China as
well who is speaking on behalf of Europe
if we look at the visits of the recent
six months Olive Schultz Sean Michelle
Pedro Sanchez Emmanuel macron Ursula Van
Der Mile and and you sir as well Mr
Burrell should have gone
each had their own specific message
rather than having a single
voice
surely we need to think about what our
message should be now we should work
together and do that only then is
Europe strong enough to fight China Miss
Funderland I think we know what the uh
message should be if you look at my
report on a renew
renewed China policy we approve that
part that report here and Mr Burrell in
your speech you're very clear about the
academic approach and in terms of what
we need to do politically but you were
clear about the four priorities so I
think there is consensus about the
content
we should look at the Chinese Military
Support to Russia and refuse to accept
that we need to stop and the violence in
the Strait of Taiwan you should not
accept that and we should not close
their eyes as systematic abuse of human
rights of course we need to be open to
work with China on crucial challenges
such as climate change but we need to
work together and act in unison let us
not be drawn apart by the Chinese
strategy Mr Weber you're just entering
into their game stop doing that let's
not be pitted one against the other
that's what China wants of course we
have to work on strategic or ten
autonomy we need to send that message
clearly to China and I think the answer
is very simple
we cannot allow ourselves to be divided
over China because we have far too much
to lose thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr valdemons now for
two and a half minutes Mr Boutique
president president thunderline
HIV P Burrell
for an organization that cherishes unity
in diversity as we do in the EU it's
never easy to talk with one voice
all the more grateful we can be
that we have heard strong and clear
voices recently regarding the eu's China
policy
and I want to start by congratulating
president Wonderland for her China's
speech and for how she conducted her
visit in China that showed leadership
there are of course as you have said
Joseph the of course different interests
but that cannot be an excuse for
Divergence on the fundamentals
the focus on human rights is not an
Assessor
for our foreign policy it's at the
center and we're not selling it for a
lentil stew
we're willing to cooperate with our
systemic rival China
but cooperation cannot be a one-way
Street
and we have to be clear-eyed
China is a revisionist power with
hegemonic ambition
aiming at building a beijing-centric
Global Order
if they would respect the principles of
the United Nations they would have
called for Russia to leave Ukraine alone
we must work together with like-minded
partners
in our China policy in particular in
cooperation with the U.S
whoever splits that front is not serving
our own values and interests strategic
autonomy Allah says would be risky for
Europe
Mutual solidarity with democracies is
basic and that includes taiwan's
democracy
in our relations with countries of the
global South we must strive to be a
better partner for them than China
and we must as has been laid out by the
present de-risk in our economic
relations in order to secure our
economies
there's no way back therefore to the
win-win illusion that shaped Cai
and at the end let me say
we should never confuse the Chinese
people and the great Chinese culture and
their successes with the dictatorship of
the totalitarian Xi Jinping regime thank
you
[Applause]
thank
you very much Mr putico for now for one
and a half minutes Mr touch
good morning Mr Burrell
the People's Republic of China is a
strategic
rival and adversary of Europe's
interests and the whole of the Free
World that you're as part of along with
the United States and day by day it's
penetrating further into Africa in South
America Asia and in Europe itself as we
are seeing selling or buying up a lot of
our infrastructures in our ports and our
Railway Networks
and we're selling them off of course
finally
in this place where we do so much
useless stuff we did something good we
put together a report on a new China
strategy dated September 2021 and it
said clearly that we need to wean
ourselves off this
dependence which had been brought up
brought about over years and years and
was killing us but now people want to
put their own ideological interests
first and they are defending them rather
than calling for China to show any sort
of reciprocity and people have been
going to Beijing one after another to
defend their own national interests
Germany is increasing its trade with
China every year it's his biggest
trading partner and the president of
France and the president of the
commission have traveled to Beijing
which were pretty much a complete
disaster for
Europe apart from some French companies
Europe
can't stop trading with China but it
needs to bring claw back a lot of the
delocalizations that have happened and
start some of the ones that make or
macron and vondolina been
planning with Beijing and their
microphones cut off Phil thank you very
much Mr tatch
no no no no no no no no no no no
thank you Mr touch
okay
yes
I thought that Mr hofstadt would start
shouting that this wasn't fair
I have written down who I interrupted
and when against my own conviction
I allowed all of the political group
leaders to have as much speaking time as
they took I didn't interrupt anybody
normally after five seconds I would
interrupt Mr tach we can go through the
minutes
yes I was writing it down
31 seconds
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I have noted it down very clearly
and I want to avoid conflict with those
who always go over time in the first
round
I allowed many people to go over the
overtime many people did that some did
it less so in the second round Mr touch
Miss
oh
all parliamentarians are equal
excuse me excuse me excuse me
at the time you at the time you have
been a group leader you have you have
you have you have you have sufficiently
profited and took to benefit of the
first round
um inextensive so and when I when I try
it to make the difference not to harsh
then I reduce the speaking times to
exceed we have 34 minutes delay I can
show you my I took my minutes I took my
minutes and we go to the records Nexus
the next speaker is Mr Mariani
for two minutes
that seems Emmanuel Macau has given rise
to a lot of emotion for those who want
to completely give in to China
after his recent visit in April 2023 in
re-asserting the traditional position of
France a position that's been the same
since 1968 on one China and affirming
that an ally is not a vassal he's quite
simply reiterated a consistent position
of France since General de gaulle's time
and that visibly has given has risen the
Heckle hackles of a number of those who
would like to send Europe on a crusade
against Beijing this reaction once again
is a flagrant illustration that the
European Union cannot be a geopolitical
independent actor
peoples Nations and interests are so
different
they cannot come up with a single
response to what is at stake in the
world and at one stage Or Another We're
gonna have to accept that diversity
France thanks to its seatum the security
Council on its nuclear deterrent has to
pursue a different path in the way that
we address these issues and Emmanuel
macaw has done that in international
politics he likes to
pronounce these gauleest approaches to
make sure that the supranational
institutions like Europe the European
Union ones have to take note
and of course many others would like to
see that but as soon as France takes a
different position to the United States
they're worried France and the European
Union has everything in the interest to
make sure that we're strategically
independent these are the both the us as
with China the American inflation
reduction Act is a frontal attack
against our jobs and our companies at
the moment we haven't said anything
about this extra territorial action of
American law and the soft power of China
and the semiconductor issue is just as a
threat for the European Union
so the European Union has to leave
behind its naivety both when it comes to
China and to the US
thank you very much Mr Mariani
now miss Demi Ralph for two minutes
thank you president well EU citizens
want the escalation rather than further
War more than ever but in the so-called
indo-pacific region there's a
geopolitical storm broom and this may
well lead to armed conflict between the
United States and China the U.S sees its
Global hegemony threatened by China
the Asian market is becoming more and
more important China is the second
largest economic power and dominates
many Supply chains and the rise of China
reduces Western businesses share of the
global market and that's something that
the United States doesn't like and
that's why we're building this Narrative
of Chinese escalation and attacks on
democracy
colleagues since when have we been
bothered by dictators and autocrats
being our partners
I don't think the United States cares
about defending democracy or the people
of Taiwan they just care about power
China hasn't done anything to Taiwan
they haven't changed their policy the
Europeans were quite happy to agree with
this one one country to policies uh uh
policy two systems policies uh when they
wanted to open up their markets to China
and sell things to China but they're not
happy now for some reason now don't
misunderstand what I'm saying I
criticized China for its Imperial
Ambitions in the world just as I
criticized the United States and the EU
but I think
the reactions to what Mr macron said
which was nothing new a very telling
colleagues please
I have never thought that uh president
macron was a leader he got the police to
beat French workers who pushed through a
pension reform but then when he doesn't
want to be taken to War by the United
States he's right I mean I don't think
world war is in the interest of the
citizens of Europe thank you
thank you Miss tamarelle now for one
minute Mr ratajkovski
is
still and so long ago not so long ago
the EU was speaking badly about China
just about everywhere we were saying
it's a non-democratic country that they
Bridge against human rights and ilham
totik got the Sakura price the Chinese
Communists visited Moscow and then the
U.S got scared that there would be no
fights anymore a misunder lion changed
her narrative and I quote China is a
fascinating and a complex mixture of
history and challenges
the hypocrisy reaches the heights of the
Statue of Liberty or the Eiffel Tower
Miss funder lion this is hypocrisy you
would
really you should really lead the NATO
together with our Slovak president who
would love to fight all around the world
until the end of her life the poor woman
and I wish to People's Republic of China
a lot of success I wish this to all
China including Taiwan chiangwa daising
ladies and gentlemen
in our relations with China
we still have that
triangle that is still in place
I think the economic relations with
China should work within a functioning
WTO that's how we should wheel deal with
things if we don't have a CIA but
everybody has to stick to the rules that
are in application at the same time we
have to make sure that we don't have any
dependencies on individual raw materials
we shouldn't have those dependents it's
not question of decoupling because our
mutual dependence is too great and so we
should make sure that the Chinese
fragmentation see this
and we would be hurting ourselves and
them if if that were the case and also
receive the effects on Taiwan as well ah
answer has to be clear no change
in the relationship with Taiwan of a
violent nature Xi Jinping has to
understand that the regional
implications are too great and too
uncalculable if they were to be violence
in relations between China and Taiwan
it's correct the we as Europe need to
Define Our Own Way vis-a-vis China and
it's just as right that we don't
necessarily have identical interests
with the US on all issues so when it
comes to War and Peace we cannot mess
around we can't say well if Taiwan is
being attacked this is only a concern of
the U.S and we just carry on with
business as usual we need to work
together and work preventatively so it
doesn't come to a worst case scenario
and in order to do that we need an
ongoing dialogue all stakeholders with
China and our message would be best to
be a single one Mr President
thank you very much Mr Gala
now for two minutes Mr belka
madam
Mr President
vice presidents
it is obvious that the EU needs a
coherent strategy for its relations with
China as recent talks in Beijing are
simply not approve of that
even if we rightly revisit our
perception of China and try to defend
our policy objectives
it may all go nothing for for nothing
when some leaders think that they have
more rights than others in setting the
course of our common foreign policy
regardless of the final list of
objectives it was is and always will be
true that the union speaking with one
voice in the international area Arena
May achieve a lot
divided becomes a bystander
bystander in World politics
and what should we expect of our
relations with China
foremost pragmatism based on a couple of
simple simple facts First China is not
our friend an ally who will play by our
Book of Rules
as it believes that power is more
important than business it will not shy
away from using subsidies and coercing
actions for example to achieve its goals
we have to be ready to respond to that
second China demands respect from the
world
we should be ready to pay it provided we
make it clear to Beijing that it will
not come at the cost to our core values
we will also remain engaged in Asian
politics in order to guarantee peace and
prosperity for all our partners
we should support the development of our
mutual trade but at the same time create
a working
roadmap on decreasing other other
Reliance from China in various sectors
and finally Beijing should not assume we
will abandon our transatlantic relation
with the U.S even in Washington if
Washington sometimes acts like an
irritating relative at the Christmas
table
America will always remain a part of our
Democratic family
what we should in turn communicate to
China is that we will not become a
balancer in its rivalry with the US
instead we should declare and pursue an
independent policy agenda which will
ultimately only serve European interests
and the global rule basis order
achieving this autonomous Position will
be a final stress test
for the concept of EU open strategic
autonomy thank you
okay I was careful here but I was
talking about something with the
services so that was perhaps my fault it
can happen I apologize anyway our next
speaker
is Miss Mrs fedrin for one minute please
foreign
China is still an authoritarian regime
and the undermining democracy in Taiwan
and Hong Kong they are a systemic rival
an adversary
to our unity in Europe during recent
years
we
have given the Chinese Communist Party
almost full control of the supply chain
we need to move away from this
dependency we need to produce more and
better in Europe and we need to ensure
our sustainable access to raw materials
we need to protect our
strategic infrastructure we need to
fight for Europeans against economic
coercion and against Chinese
interference our legislative Arsenal
needs to be completed and then used it
is time to ensure that we can take
decisions on our own behalf we need to
be able to
have a democratic European and credible
strategy which is genuinely effective
thank you dear colleagues just a piece
of information because we are a bit
pressed for time we will not be able to
take any more cashdi requests therefore
at the moment and those will be allowed
to speak but there will be no no more
requests taken thank you very much
you have the floor
as we know one of our weaknesses as you
is the difficulty in establishing
unified and coherent foreign policy
strategies that this would happen to us
with what is one of the most relevant
strategies our relationship with China
would be particularly serious
we have indeed a good basic basis to
update such a strategy in president from
the Reliance recent speech at the EPC
which I can endorse almost from top to
bottom but if we send contradictory
messages to Xi Jinping we lose
credibility
for instance as when President macron
says what he said in relation to Taiwan
the maintenance of the status quo and
the Taiwanese trade is not an internal
matter if it breaks down due to
increasing Chinese aggressiveness this
will have Regional and international
repercussions as everyone knows we
cannot break the fragile European
consensus on such sensitive issues with
unilateral steps such as this with China
we need to establish a relationship that
takes into account both the evolution of
the Chinese regime in recent years more
authoritarianism and more willingness to
shape the international order as well as
our own interests and this implies
cooperating bilaterally and
multilaterally whenever possible
reducing the enormous strategic
dependencies that we have which
represent a high economic risk and never
ever giving up in the defense of Human
Rights and Democratic Values
thank you very much
you have the floor
thank you chair uh ladies and gentlemen
dear colleagues let's be very Frank to
ourselves you Channel relations are not
good they could be better and they
should be better
and let me make three points on that
first I think that we need to find new
equilibrium with China because like it
or not China is here as a global player
and it will remain so and we have to
adjust ourselves to that new multi-polar
situation secondly I believe that we
need cohabitation rather than
confrontation and therefore I was glad
to hear particularly from the commission
president that we are starting to talk
about the risking instead of decoupling
because that in my feeling is a rational
policy and thirdly last but not least I
believe that we need to de-escalate
tensions over Taiwan not to escalate
further and I think there are ways to do
that perhaps we could also listen a
little bit more what the kmt opposition
has to say about cross-trade relations
and not just the ruling DPP I can hear
Mr macron's call for strategic autonomy
and yes if there is a case there is no
better case than China for a strategic
autonomy but it deserves to be realistic
to be pragmatic and to be reasonable on
our side thank you very much
thank you very much and now we have Jag
Madison you have the floor
you are waiting for all the speeches to
listen uh first of all we have to
understand what does it mean to have the
common foreign policy to over China as
in China there is a one capital in the
U.S there is one capital and we have
joined the seven capitals so when we
have some kind of common line who's
setting up the common line common policy
when we're talking about climate policy
when we talk about the trade policy
about defense about the military
and we can see like very different
opinions from Paris to Berlin and to our
student also in Eastern countries
so that's why it's a bit like
confusing to hear about the messages
from from Paris from Mr macron that we
need strategic autonomy
it could be very nice idea of course but
what will the EU do European country
will do what will France do
when China will attack Taiwan
when there is some kind of tensions in
in France that we shouldn't rely too
much on the U.S okay fine what is
alternative have we invested enough to
the defense no just now we check the
facts France has given to Ukraine
military aid twice less than Germany or
the same level with Greece
and we are still
waiting for the end of the war and we
are not capable
to win the war as soon as possible
and when there's a new war in Taiwan yes
we can make some very nice resolutions
and make some statements just we support
democracy the human rights and values
yeah they really care about that in
China but other the fact about the
democracy and the human rights yes I
know that in Parliament will like to
export all the same values in every
corner whole world and I'm not really a
fan of that
we should also take care of the economic
fact when we are dreaming about the
green deal electric cars in Taiwan
they're producing over 60 percent of the
world's semiconductors
and when Taiwan is gone
then good luck with your green deal and
electric cars
so now it's just like the crucial
question
are we choosing the Chinese side
talking like to talk like just very nice
word yeah let's be part of let's be
friends or we are understanding The
Realistic world that we have rival on
the Chinese and Russian side and we have
a partner on the American side because
we are not capable here to invest enough
in our defense and in our economy thank
you so much
thank you very much
you have the floor
president thank you president for the
debate on EU relations with China
poses a dilemma
should we have an independent foreign
policy based on our interests
or should we continue to Outsource our
foreign policy to organizations and
bodies that base their decisions on
interests that are different
if not in direct opposition to ours
the interventions
of President Wonderland and Mr Burrell
are not cause for optimism in this sense
Europe needs to be an independent player
in the development of an open and
multi-polar International order an order
that is based on mutually beneficial
multilateral relations and also on the
founding Charter of the UN
in order to ensure an independent EU
foreign policy we need to normalize
relations with China
president XI Jin ping extended a hand in
meetings with EU leaders and we need to
take that hand
because we can't build the future of the
planet without China
no one can deny that improving relations
with China China excuse me would be
beneficial for the EU and its people
let's not fall into the Trap being
set by those who feel that their Global
hegemony is under threat let's not do
their dirty work let's defend European
interests from a position of
Independence
let's activate the agreements with China
that have been Frozen as a result of
political decisions that benefit others
but which are damaging for our people
let's recognize that the peace plan that
China is presenting can open a path to
other plans
you can together with other plans such
as that from president Lula can open a
path to negotiations for peace in
Ukraine let's have the EU being part of
the solution rather than active part of
the problem
let's not continue along a path that is
leading to a cold war situation with the
world divided into various economically
separate blocks a world that would be
damaging in the short term in economic
terms
but would also in the medium term put us
on the verge of a nuclear Holocaust
we want dialogue Independence and most
importantly we want peace thank you
president
thank you very much and next we'll have
Milan Rick you have the floor
thank you very much colleague
a French president macron after visiting
China has said that Europe needs more
strategic autonomy
and that it shouldn't be vessel to the
United States I do not tend to agree
with the model macron but this time I
will make an exception and I think he
was right because the current EU policy
doesn't make sense and it destroys
Europe first you led us into conflict
with Russia because it's in the foreign
policy interest of the USA then you
adopted liquidatory policies and
sanctions to force us to buy more
expensive guns from the United States
now you are pushing us into
confrontation with China because USAC
China as a threat to its World dominance
instead of Europe I mean Europe
grasping and seizing the opportunity
which the developing Asia presents you
see threat in everyone or you see an
enemy in everyone soon we'll be adopting
sanctions against the entire world and
the world will be isolated but we are
going to end up isolated it's high time
really high time to end this
confrontation policy thank you
yeah
thank you
you have the floor
the president
commissioners
ladies and gentlemen
I believe that our policy on China is in
fact quite clear
to collaborate where possible to compete
where needed and to confront when
necessary
we need to make ourselves a little less
dependent on China we need to make
ourselves more self-reliant on defense
but basically the policy can continue
indefinitely for Mutual benefit
but we have two red lines
don't arm Russia
don't attack Taiwan
if you arm Russia we all have a trade
War
if you attack Taiwan
then despite what some say or wish we
would eventually come down on the side
of our Ally the United States
therefore I have a piece of advice and a
plea
don't repeat Russia's catastrophic
mistake instead help her get out of it
thank you
[Applause]
Elizabeth thank you very much now we
have Elizabeth
thanks Mr president vice president
president of the commission we've
finally heard some truth when it comes
to relations between the EU and China
because Mr Burrell is not just a
question of formally dividing up the
work who does what we need to give
powerful political messages we need a
political Vision it's good therefore
that Ms vonder Lyon talked about the
risks de-risking instead of decoupling
we can't decouple from our trade
relations which be absurd it's good the
macron said we can't be followers of the
United States we need to look for our
third way we need to look for autonomy
but there have to be two conditions
first of all China needs to cooperate
when it comes to
peace negotiations with the old pal
Putin but also foreign policies never
divorced from internal aspects Europe's
a big great to democracy so we're
defending democracy in the Ukraine so
why shouldn't be defend it in Taiwan as
well we need to talk about this but we
need to talk powerfully we need more
policy and less bureaucracy thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss Nicola bear you have the floor I
hadn't mentioned
China limits freedom and human rights
China is boosting its cooperation with
auditorian authoritarian regimes in
Russia and China and this is an alarming
development with a view to Russia's war
in Ukraine and the international order
who still believes that they can
influence what China does through
pro-china trade policies or by political
finger-pointing you must stand together
and nail our colors to the Mast standing
by Taiwan is in line with both our
values and our interests together with
our transatlantic allies we must clearly
show Beijing how high the cost of an
attack on Taiwan would be
our message is clear
those who cause breaches of the peace
will trigger a political Firestorm from
which there can be no winners
in addition as the EU we must boost our
economic and geopolitical position in a
decisive and United manner
we must push
our interests build Partnerships and
ensure sovereignty for example by
dealing with issues relating to the
supply of raw materials with reliable
Partners that's what Europe should do
thank you
thank you and the next speaker is Miss
Henry caham
in Europe we don't need an anti-china
hysteria nor naivety neither is
appropriate China for Europe is an
important trade partner we need to work
together on climate protection and green
future Industries and China is number
one when it comes to greenhouse gas
emissions so we can't ignore that
Europe and China however are not
like-minded partners by any stretch of
the imagination if you look at forced
workers in shenzhang and so it's
important that we have cooperation but
to have a decoupling of relations with
China is not an option but when it comes
to risks we need to reduce our risks and
become more independent but we need to
strengthen our approach from within and
that's what we're doing by having the
Net Zero
industry act the critical materials Act
and the chips Act
but given the economic obligations of
the EU
we cannot just throw out and eject all
of our values we still need to apply
social criteria that has to be the
European approach in the EU we need a
common European strategy for a China
which has declared that it will be a
world power in 2049 and the current
status of Taiwan cannot be unilaterally
changed and certainly not by military
means when it comes to critical sectors
we're going to have to look very closely
at trade instruments need to be
sharpened we need to see if imports and
exports are in harmony with our security
and climate interests
and in doing that we will not forget our
dialogue between us and China thank you
thank you very much and the next speaker
is Mr Carlo finanza you have the floor
thank you president High representative
vice president there's a cue to meet Xi
Jinping now in China after Chancellor
Schultz prime minister Sanchez Michelle
vonder Lyons Saudi Arabian Taliban
ministers the last few days we had two
people from the radical lift president
Lula from Brazil who made it very clear
where he stood in the division between
democracy and autocracy there's also the
European side Mr macron who tried to get
back a bit of popularity at home posing
as a new de goal all he achieved though
was divided in the west dividing Europe
which has now got an Eastern flank
exposed to Russian expansionism and
abandoning Taiwan at the same time
talking about the Strategic autonomy but
forgetting that he was his crass Ultra
all environmental policies which are
going to condemn us to ever greater
dependence on communist China and that
is not a consistent strategy thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr yohakim course
president
thank you president Mr Burrell
colleagues
oh where
we're focusing on coming up with a joint
strategy as to how we can work with and
deal with
China
but as we do that
one of the main EU Representatives
is throwing sand into the gearbox
I'm talking about President macron here
he
stay says that perhaps Europe is getting
too involved in the conflict over
between China and Taiwan and Mr Weber
but
Mr Vapor others have also agreed with uh
what Mr macron has said I mean
criticizing is easy but it's better to
understand colleagues what can we learn
out of the events of recent weeks if we
believe that we can criticize China
openly and dictate what it's going to do
well I think it's pretty clear that
that's not going to be possible
China has shown us that the result is
absolutely nothing
macro however was welcomed with a red
carpet
and came home with a series of fat
contracts president on the line no red
carpet No military parade no press
conference with President XI that is the
political reality when it comes to
relations between the EU and China
colleagues let's be honest about this
China sees us as
an extended branch of the United States
and until we can emancipate ourselves
from that situation that won't change
and then any discussions on relations or
strategies with or vis-a-vis China will
simply lead to nothing
that's something that none of us can
want colleagues thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Mick Wallace
Mr brother
if the EU should have a coherent
strategy for the EU China relations it
should not originate in Brussels
we just had the embarrassing spectacle
of the commission president speaking
ahead of a major diplomatic visit to
China and slinging accusations at a
Chinese government that has scanned
connection to reality
the remarks were so bizarre and
contradictory it was difficult to
decipher who their intended audience was
the fact is that some of your countries
have good relations trade and otherwise
with China and other EU countries are
less enthusiastic
there's a Washington campaign to counter
China's economic influence in the world
so we see U.S talking points about
internal repression and assertive
Behavior abroad being pirated by EU
Representatives while the U.S has no
problem growing its trade and investment
with China year on year
U.S financial Capital wants to make
profits in China and in Europe and
driving a wage between the EU and China
is a good way of going about it for them
and very sadly there's people in
Brussels who appear to be helping them
to do this
thank you the next speaker is Mr Nicola
Bay Kelly shake it what a humiliating
failure for Emmanuel macron who pulled
off the double whammy of getting nothing
from Beijing and simultaneously
upsetting our closest allies going to
China speaking on behalf of Europe
without any mandate from the council
talking too much as usual the firming
positions are contrary to those of many
of our friends and allies remember my
Quran once again humiliated France and
weakened the European on taunt it's even
more shameful because he didn't have any
political courage he went and told the
Chinese exactly what they wanted to hear
but strong claims he's not the follower
of Washington but he finally showed
himself subservient to Beijing and yet
if Europeans have a common interest when
it comes to China it needs to be treated
her as she is a trade partner yes not
always a loyal trade partner far from it
and particularly in particular a
systemic rival when he um of whom we
need to wean off our dependence and the
US and China both protect their
interests we need to stop
being foolish and feeble in the face of
those who take advantage the delighted
beneficiaries of our disability thank
you
president
thank you president
Mrs vice president
having a coherent to youth strategy in
our relations with China yes that's
something we need we have to speak with
a single voice
president Fonda lion was very strong in
her reaction to the aggressive
efforts of China and that's the right
path to tread we need to make sure that
we share this path with people who share
our values however Mr macro was
counterproduction because if the
attention was playing good cop Badcock
with the Chinese then this buttering up
Allah Source macron was something that
went completely down the spout on the
issue of Taiwan I am also falling on the
side of Miss
from the line of Mr Viber not on Mr
macron
to support a burgeoning liberal
democracy is not as something that is
just an American issue it is in the core
interest of Europe as well if you want
to de-risk when it comes to our supply
chains then we have to have Partners we
can rely on and part of this is to
ratify the Microsoft agreements we
should do that in this term of office
because the economic situation Argentina
does not allow us to wait if we don't
want to allow the Chinese to have
priority once again I'm very pleased to
hear that Mr Lambert appears to have
recognized this as well because it's
only by doing this that we'll be able to
achieve a sustainable transition and in
doing so this is what we have to do to
promote the European sovereignty which
is also necessary
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr tonino Pizza you have the floor the
key question today is what is our common
position on China we witnessed weekly
visits of member states and
institutional leaders to China but we
certainly lack coherence
our relations with China should not
become another issue that creates
internal divisions one does not prove
strategic autonomy by being autonomous
from other member states and
institutional leaders should think twice
before providing EU cover for individual
visits our relations with China also
reflect our Global Ambitions we have
some strategies and global gateway but
we are lagging in practice we are number
one world donor but China is a number
one trading partner for 120 countries
worldwide moreover in the last 20 years
more than 40 countries reverted to
semi-autocratic or autocratic regimes
therefore European Union cannot simply
walk away from traditional alliances
that Define the future of democracy and
only United Europe is a strong Europe
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Dragon you have the floor thank you
chair dear colleagues
I think we all agree that we want a
stronger more powerful Union
it is in the interest of Our member
states our citizens and in the interest
of our strategic Partners this debates
are therefore not be about choosing
sites our Partnerships are clear they
cannot be unfollowed
in our competitors and Rivals also well
known and we have a strategy on how to
deal with them so let's focus Less on
semantics and more on actions needed to
improve our capabilities and develop
coherent foreign policy tools playing
with the 50 Shades of strategic autonomy
and then wasting time elucidating their
significance is not only weakening our
Global position but it is strengthening
our rivals China wants nothing more than
to see us divided
all priorities should be clear the
Taiwan Strait and the indo-pacific must
remain free and open
China must respect International rules
from trade to technology all the way to
the right of Ukraine to its sovereignty
and integrity on the U.N Charter so
let's focus on delivering that thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Yanik shadow
colleagues
are we being led by goldfish goldfish
who have forgotten all the lessons from
the war in Ukraine and are repeating the
same economic and political errors and
you've got Olaf Schultz going to China
and saying the same things to see Xi
Jinping that he previously said to Putin
the interests of Volkswagen are more
important to him than the wig or people
and then macron as well he went to China
to defend France's interests private
interests and he then showed a full
non-alignment with his allies he showed
that Europe's divided he
made the Ally made alliances more
fragile and he made the situation in
Ukraine and Taiwan more fragile too he
basically did the work of everyone who
is from the far right or who supports
anti-American dictatorships and
autocrats we can't work like that
the issue is not to know who we're
aligned with the issue is to know what
we're aligned on we need to be aligned
on our values and the unity of Europe we
need to focus on human rights and we
need to base ourselves on our values so
the by European act and embargo on all
products that are produced using forced
labor and we need to protect our
Industries as the United States are
doing we need to align ourselves on our
values and we need to stand together
thank you thank you very much now Mr
jislovsky you have the floor
thank you very much president the recent
Europe visits by European leaders to
China showed that Europe's not the same
as its European institutions and that
Europe's highly varied and diverse
president macron
the German foreign minister the
president of the European commission all
show different facets of Europe's
strategy uh strategy up to now has been
unsatisfactory Europe is weakened and
China is strengthened a common strategy
can be created only
when we have this kind of debate between
the various interests and member states
have the right to defend national
interests including president macron
it's only under such conditions that
will avoid the errors that we committed
in our relations with Russia and I think
today's debate unfortunately is not
health
foreign
will awake the Earth will shake that's
what Napoleon said China has awoken and
the Earth is shaking we can see the soft
soaping strategism Miss from the line on
others which are not helping
and we hear Mr macron talking about
things that only the Chinese want to
hear there doesn't seem to be any common
line against China
I've taken some examples but the
Electoral electric car is perfect
example stopping a sale of combustion
engines by 2035 is handing the advantage
in industrial terms to China because all
the metals that are necessary to put
forward to produce batteries are in
China and that is the only way you can
have competitive electric cars so that's
the suicidal European automobile
strategy
that's just one example that the
delocalization strategy of globalization
that we've seen for at least five years
is something that's helping China as
well if we don't break that policy we'll
remain prisoners thank you
thank you very much and now Mr Ivan
Villa
you have the floor
thank you very much dear colleagues we
are witnesses to creation of a
multi-polar world which is unavoidable
so let's talk about this future it's not
only China that is the problem but also
in the Latin America Indonesia and so on
the time of the Strong West is under
Decline and the political leads of the
West are to blame for there always right
they never make mistakes and they are
never held responsible
and they also keep meeting with their
cronies from Davos and they're not
interested in demonstrations of millions
of citizens Elites instead of
strengthening the citizens and the
prosperity are more interested in the
portfolio of BlackRock and this leads to
the fact that the influence of a West
will only be a shadow of its former self
the one who is most likely to lose is
Europe if we continue with these
policies we will become poppers not
respected not consulted and our economy
will become a museum of industrial
Heritage for smaller countries as
Croatia and this is better because they
will have more room for development if
they cannot find understanding in one
place they will find it at another no
more black males no more oppression
Croatia will be able to use business
opportunities in the rest of the world
which it could not do in the past it is
time for a new age
you have the floor thank you Mr
President High representative executive
vice president's four points on my side
on China firstly reduce dependencies on
China we saw with regards to the Russian
Federation any dependency on an
undemocratic on an autocratic regime can
be a vulnerability to the European Union
it is a significant risk to the European
Union particularly in times of Crisis we
should learn from this we should invest
in research Innovation use our single
Market modernize our digital single
Market make sure that our companies
become even more competitive on the
global scale so that we are as less
dependent on China as possible first
point second Point economically China is
a significant partner to us we are a
significant partner to them we are the
largest export market for Chinese
products so so we should work and insist
on reciprocity improve access to the
Chinese market for European companies
make sure that condition for European
companies in China are being improved
and unfair practices are being
terminated thirdly values values are
important to us we should not compromise
on values a selfie with a communist
Chinese leader should not be a goal for
the European Union or for any politician
coming from the European Union when
visiting China China will not respect us
if we are weak our objective needs to be
to improve our position towards China
Speak Up on human rights
also when it is difficult and fourthly
the relation with the United States and
other allies we need to give a clear
message the alliances that we are
members of the alliances of the Free
World are important to the European
Union so our allies we are sticking
together the objective of China is to
have the upper hand in relations to the
European Union we have to avoid this
thank you very much
thank you president commissioner higher
representative
well
we need a consistent strategy I think we
should leave
theater aside here and really establish
our own interests so let me make a
couple of points on this firstly
what is the situation
when it comes to trade with uh China
well 95 percent of it is non-critical
five percent of it is critical so I
think we need to strengthen areas where
it is critical such as raw materials for
example second
we can we
defend our interests uh in the face of
coercion well yes we have the foreign
subsidies act Etc so we have the
legislation in place then thirdly we
need cooperation in those areas which
are of particular interest to us such as
for example the reduction in CO2
emissions and the CO2 price we need
China involved in that and then a fourth
point we need to rely work closely with
reliable partners because we are in
competition with China so we need more
bilateral trade agreements and I think
that would help us to defend our
interests as well thank you very much
thank you very much next speaker is
Nicola Dante you have the floor
thank you Mr President High
representative vice president three key
words to try to define a China strategy
in one minute first of all
competitiveness China is an
insignificant economic competitor in
this sense strategic autonomy is a key
element to avoid us being in an inferior
position but to achieve it we need to
start to play our role in the world all
over again starting with a partnership
with Africa and ratifying the mercosura
treaty abandoning political myopia of
the last few years and strengthening our
links with the
South American continent secondly
cooperation the huge Chinese markets as
it's huge
extraordinary opportunity for our
companies just as we are for them
thirdly rules
clear rules on intellectual property on
security and user privacy as well as
institutions which will
Safeguard European investments in China
three words which are just a beginning a
start of a care message with clear
message we need to send out from this
house any hostile act against Taiwan or
direct or indirect support to Putin's
regime won't be tolerated and will have
extreme consequences on the economic
front as well
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss Marketa gregorova you have the
floor
dear colleagues
China is a big country and you are small
countries and that is a fact that's what
China's foreign minister said in 2010
and because individually we are 27 proud
but small countries formats like 14 plus
one and fleshy State visits of national
presidents are playing right in the
hands of Beijing and if the commission
president or high representative are
coming along but are clearly playing
side role I wonder if this benefits us
Europeans at all and how much it harms
our Taiwanese allies or uighur friends
increasing International attention is
forcing us to become serious about
European foreign policy that means
qualified majority vote in the council
and treat a change that means EAS with a
mandate
that means that we can discuss content
hopefully next time and not how
disunited we stand globally at the
moment thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Adam bielen you have the floor uh Mr
President the commissioner EU China
relations have deteriorated rapidly over
the past years leading to a more realist
approach focusing on sharper economic
competition and systemic rivalry in view
of the latest developments including the
kovi 19 pandemic sanctions for human
rights violations and China's actions
against selected member states the EU
should enhance its resilience diversify
markets and secure Supply chains
moving forward we should work towards a
more balanced and sustainable approach
to our relations with China based on
strategic priorities in this regard I
believe there is an opportunity to
cooperate on a positive agenda such as
an on cooperation in biodiversity
sustainable development and climate
change
these engagement should be on equal
terms and based on the principle of
reproversity
while China remains a competitor partner
and systemic rival the EU must strive to
reduce its dependency on China while
simultaneously engaged in constructive
dialogue thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss Clara ponzatio bills you have the
floor
when we talk about China and human
rights we talk about individual and
Collective freedoms we talk about
repression of minorities as a case of
the euros and the right of
self-determination as it is in Taiwan
but Europe will not get respect until we
first do our own homework Europe has a
choice it can act like a big Switzerland
or be a bad copy of China we can be a
union grounded on communities based on
self-determination where Prosperity is
fueled by diversity Ingenuity and
freedom or by looking the other way when
Nations peoples and political rights are
vexed we will become a degraded version
of an authoritarian regime Europe has a
lot of homework and Catalonia is a test
to check progress so far
we're failing thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Jurgen valborn you have the flow
Mr President the European Union stands
for open rules-based and fair trade
we are also the foremost defender of
democracy freedom and human dignity
it is no news that China is very
different it's a communist autocracy
with massive State control of the market
denying its citizens basic human rights
and threatening its peaceful Neighbors
China cannot be treated like any other
trading partner
we want to have a close relationship and
we want to increase the trade but that
requires a positive movement from China
of Human Rights being granted subsidies
abandoned and the freedom of the
Taiwanese people
respected we shall not seek unnecessary
confrontation but we need to show
firmers towards China and be crystal
clear about what is right and what is
wrong
this should be done in unity with
partners and especially the
transatlantic partnership needs to be
reinforced further
in addition we must drastically reduce
our dependency on China for critical raw
materials and device diversify our
supply chains this could be done with
the merkasaur treaty free trade
agreements with the Australia and New
zealands
so in summary we shall cooperate where
beneficial we shall compete when needed
and confront when necessary thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss inma Rodriguez Pinero you have the
floor
thank you Mr President Mr Dominos Mr
Burrell I'm going to talk about two key
aspects to bear in mind in our relations
with China first of all trade relations
they've worsened considerably there's an
unsustainable deficit we're too
dependent on certain fundamental raw
materials and there are differences in
their laws secondly China's role is a
global player which has to play a bigger
role in defending human rights peace
stability in The Straits of Taiwan put
an end to Putin's war and help fight
climate change the union needs strategic
autonomy that's open if we want to
achieve more balanced relations
reciprocal relations relations based on
Fair competition and defense of our own
interests so I welcome the new diff
trade defense instruments for critical
raw materials but Mr dombroski's we need
to have a
measures to control investments from
abroad into the European unit we need to
be consistent and coordinate our
relations with Beijing so it's vital I
think
that
we make sure that the high
representative I congratulations on his
work should be in charge of that thank
you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss Karin Karls Brown you have the
floor
president
commissioner the council colleagues
this debate has been very much
anticipated especially since President
Van Der leyen and president bakron's
recent visit to China
this is not the first time the EU
appears divided on matters of foreign
policy who is the spokesperson for the
EU is it Borel Michel Van Der leyan
macron or is it trolls this underlines
the need for a renewed and coherent EU
China strategy the EU must continue to
be the voice for those who cannot speak
for themselves in China and there are
should be no doubt absolutely no doubt
that Europe that Europe stands with
Taiwan
we can't be afraid of aligning strategy
with our Democratic allies as
democracies we must stand together
always thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr bertian Ryerson you have the floor
thank you president
High representative commissioner ladies
and gentlemen
the China's dictatorship where human
rights are trampled underfoot is
something that we've been aware of for a
long time
in the meantime the situation in China
is not getting any better
and we're noting this in Europe now
China intimidates it threatens
journalists
it enters into large-scale Espionage
activities and then you have the
aggressive activities of um
[Music]
approach of China towards Taiwan the
worst thing we can do as the Western
world is to allow ourselves to be
divided and pit one country against
another unfortunately Mr macron has
underscored that by saying that Taiwan
is a U.S affair
transatlantic cooperation is absolutely
essential but also investments in our
independence from China is important as
well as speaking clearly about our Vital
infrastructure
a specific question to the commission
when is the new religious freedoms
Ombudsman going to China China they'll
have a lot to talk about
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr jeruso
president
colleagues president recent events
meetings between European leaders and
Chinese
leaders showed clearly how important it
is to have a European common foreign
policy Europe needs to be present to
ensure a balance we're seeing clear
tensions such as the war in Ukraine and
we're also seeing hidden tensions and
all of that requires us to play a
mediating role between other great
Powers China and the United States but
also between continents such as Africa
relations with the United States need to
uh with China excuse me to be fostered
but we shouldn't forget human rights and
also our own productive capabilities we
also need to avoid unnecessary tensions
between the United States and China
that's a task that only Europe can
fulfill but uh we need in our actions to
ensure that we're aware of how important
our role is also during the coming
decades people look at us very closely
and we also need to take account of the
climate and environment emergency which
China can cannot ignore either let's act
together thank you thank you very much
the next speaker is Mr Lucas Mandel you
have the floor thank you
thank you very much president
commissioner High representative ladies
and gentlemen it's important that the
European Union
reflect the title of this debate and has
a coherent strategy vis-a-vis the
vis-a-vis China and the Strategic
compass that we adopted recently makes
it very clear it sees China is just a
strategic partner in economic terms it's
a rival
a systemic rival in fact and all as the
three aspects need to be taken into
consideration but the systemic rival
unfortunately seems to be predominant
I've been able to visit China over the
past 15 years or so and unfortunately I
think the situation is getting worse and
worse when it comes to freedom of
expression when it comes to Human Rights
Hong Kong used to be a burgeoning uh
trade City
and we've seen what happens there and we
see what's happening on the world stage
you know look at the State of Affairs
and I'll tell you who your friends are
so let us not be friends with the
atrocities being committed in China
there is a question reciprocity it can't
be acceptable that European companies
have no legal certainty in China whereas
China has a clear legal certainty as
with everybody else in Europe and
self-evidently a strategic partnership
needs to be thought through
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr udobuuman you have the floor
president
are representative
colleagues yes president from the line
gave an interesting speech we need to
look to our economic interests and we
need to look to our technological
interests that's quite right
she also mentioned human rights that's
quite right too we're seeing massive
violations in China but
then
we need to
Act
as well I mean look at our sanctions
array
regime
we need to sanction businesses who
provide equipment that is used to
violate human rights
we need to ensure that our standards are
upheld in terms of Labor rights in Xin
Yang and other places we need to ensure
that our legislation has teeth
we need to ensure that our development
and foreign policy ensures that European
money is only
spent to benefit businesses who stick to
our human rights standards that is a
Joint Task that we need to fulfill
colleagues and it's a joint task for all
of us and All European institutions
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr jordanians you have the floor
president commissioner High
representative when one asks about the
need for a coherent strategy is either
because it's not go hearing or we
haven't got a strategy at all if it's
all three then we're really in trouble
because China does have a strategy
strategy is hegemony as you'll be aware
China started this game of hegemony
where you've got two thousand years ago
where people are struggling to control
the same territory so China has been
playing goal the game that I've just
mentioned in strategic terms all over
the world in Africa Latin America and
what's Europe been doing nothing or at
least not enough
China's a global player so the question
is do we want to be a global player or
do we want to be a piece on the goal
board I think we want to be a global
actor Global player and that's going to
cost us because if you're not a global
player you're running a risk of being a
piece on a board in a game and often
pieces like that are sacrificed thank
you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr Alexander vondra you have the floor
dear friends China is emerging
superpower and aspiring to be the global
number one therefore we definitely are
in a situation of need of having a
proper and coherent strategy but this
not be done according to lines which we
have seen the last week when President
macron
went to China to pursue the economic
interest of its own country
and as a reward to his host
offered a vision of European Equity
distance to the United States in China
at the same time
he did
even worse in the name of the EU
he was speaking about the EU strategic
in autonomy but offered a strategic
ambiguity instead and he did in a
situation when we terribly need strong
NATO
and the cooperation of the U.S in the
Ukraine next time we must do much better
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr mislaus you have the floor
their colleagues citizens
three decades ago Europe was a world
power in China was a relatively poor
country developing country
that was the time when Europe was led by
strong National politicians and today
they're Guided by men wearing dresses
today
China is a world an economic superpower
and the EU is a completely irrelevant
player on the world map apart as a
tourist destination today the European
Union is forcing production of electric
cars 95 percent of lithium without to
which electric cars cannot be produced
is produced today in China
when we impose sanctions to China after
Russia will completely hold the
production of electric cars in the EU so
this is the route we are taking
no thank you
thank you very much
the next speaker is Mr Francisco
miyanmore
thank you president will China it's a
great power it's crucial in the world
today and it's a country that the
European Union cannot ignore its
cooperation is crucial to deal with
global challenges
we need to correct the massive
imbalances in our trade relations and we
need to ensure we have less dependency
on Chinese products in some areas that
makes us vulnerable
lithium for example critical materials
that's crucial for the production of
electric vehicles for example and
depending on Chinese lithium is a
problem we need to diversify our
suppliers to avoid full dependency on
China we need to reduce risks
we could go for lithium from Chile for
example unfortunately China is trying to
change the world order which has enabled
it to develop massively over the last 20
years it's a member of the security
Council but it doesn't seem bothered by
China's violation of
the basic tenets of international law
such as not using Force it's closer to
Russia than Ukraine and that influences
our relations with China we're seeing
tensions increase between U.S and China
and the U.S is our most important
partner we must stick with Washington on
this thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
High representative the CPC is putting
the uyghurs in concentration camps the
French National Assembly has said that
there is a genocide and denounces it
this Parliament too but that doesn't
count apparently XI jinping's regime
brings down the Tibetans the Hong
kongers uses secret police in our own
cities and launches cyber attacks
against our infrastructure and our
institutions but apparently that doesn't
matter that doesn't matter to the French
president who went to Beijing and made
the same mistakes that were made in
Moscow why because we apparently need
China let me remind you that for 20
years we were told the exact same thing
about Putin's Russia we sacrificed the
ukrainians the Georgians the chechens
and more we sacrificed our principles
because we apparently needed Russia and
now there is war in Europe let's not
make the same mistake again it's not
about moralizing it's about realism if
we are indolent if we are Cupid
and we have been that has meant that
we've shifted production to China we
have
we've been hoist by our own petard
we need to be autonomous now we have to
be courageous and show what we want to
be
[Applause]
yeah
thank you next speaker
to tell you one thing I was pleased that
you got covered
I was pleased that you got covered a few
days ago
and that you didn't go to uh to China
because it had only had more kakafuni to
the possessions of Europe on China so
very well that you stay at home but I
have a request to you it's your task to
come forward now with a new strategic
paper you know the Strategic paper on
China dates from 2016.
2016. I know then we added we actualized
the paper of 2016 Mr Boutique over in
2019 and then in the meanwhile what
happened is everything what happened in
Hong Kong because everybody is talking
about Ukraine but things change
fundamentally one at the moment of Hong
Kong because the consensus worldwide was
one China two systems
and if
China doesn't this accept any more two
systems why we should accept One China
is the one or the other so my plea to
you is to come forward then fastest as
possible in the three months from coming
with new communication strategy paper on
China sending it to the council sending
it to the European Parliament and to
Define this new strategy the fastest as
possible that is what we need to do
[Applause]
sorry we're running late I am sorry
you have the floor
thank you chair
Commissioners president macron
signed an agreement in China and he
talked about strategic autonomy of
Europe however you have been building a
strategic autonomy of the EU for years
with Russia against Poland and in the
face of the war you left Europe
completely helpless militarily
economically and so on and now macron
goes to China and asks for more of the
same he talks about pushing away the US
however what would Ukraine do without
the US and Poland it would have fallen a
long time ago it would have been
completely helpless with your helmets
and your energy saving bulbs
so the the ideas of France of Germany
about autonomy has cost Europe too much
however I have an appeal to the leaders
of Eastern and Central Europe if you do
not wake up you will have autonomy but
made by Russia and China
thank you very much
presidential
Mr President it is a strategic mistake
to view our relations with China only
from the point of view of commercial
interests we should not forget about
human rights and democracy
it is dangerous to think that we need
strategic autonomy from the United
States the Chinese regime is a threat
both to the U.S and to Europe This is a
real threat the Communists have decided
to Annex Taiwan
through Force drawing on the example of
Russia's invasion of Ukraine their
doctrine of a unified China means no
independent Democratic Taiwan the
Democratic Western World should be
United if business is successful but
democracy is not this would lead to a
crisis of our values and the European
way of life thank you
foreign
[Music]
and dear colleagues now this legislature
is coming to an end it's been
characterized by the green deal by the
pandemic and by the war in Ukraine and
all of this indicates that we must
really be careful about our foreign
policy and we must be consistent we do
that when we're talking about Ukraine
but unfortunately we don't do this when
it comes to China and the cacophony of
which we've just heard is really
shameful Mr High representative and
there's no point in dealing with our
short-term economic interests we're
talking about values and our policy must
be based on values we're dealing with
China China and the human rights and the
human rights and the problems in that
country with human rights
I agree with Mr Giver of stat this isn't
always the case but in this case we are
there are two possible systems in China
we've got to be clear as far as time one
is concerned we're not going to accept
Europe must not accept that we leave
Taiwan in the note there should be no
cacophony on that score thank you
thank you very much speaker
thank you president of high
representative now one minute to speak
about China is not a lot uh it's you can
put into one minute just about what you
can put into a tweet but sometimes you
do speak too much
and sometimes we pay more attention to
words and to acts but since I don't have
a lot of time let's talk about hacks who
pushed the European Union towards
controlling foreign investment in
strategic sectors France who's playing
the role of a driving force to fight
against our dependency in terms of
semiconductors or raw materials the
French government who is the only head
of European state of European state to
have gone to Peking with the president
of the commission and I would like to
pay trippy to what she said which is
very correct well it was Emmanuel macron
now which European ship was in the
Strait of Taiwan when the Chinese Navy
was carrying out Maneuvers which were
pointless and provocative a French
frigate frigate the prairiel so I would
like to express a wish we should all try
to be as clear and firm as also refund a
lion on China and Taiwan we should all
be as committed as France is and ensure
that we translate our words into actual
action thank you very much Mrs Juliana
is next please the floor is yours
hey we are at the crucial Junction in
our relations with China while we
acknowledge China as a partner
competitor and systemic rival our
bilateral relations have become
increasingly challenging in recent years
China's recent assertive actions in the
Strait of Taiwan and its ambiguous stand
Sense on the Russian aggression in
Ukraine have further affected our
relations in this geopolitically
volatile world the European Union must
take unified position on China while
working closely with our transatlantic
candido in the Pacific allies
I welcome the recent visit of President
Van Der Lyon to China as it underscores
our commitment to maintaining an open
and constructive dialogue with China
nevertheless even as we seek to build
stronger relations with China we must
remain steadfast in highlighting human
rights abuse is maintaining a rule-based
international order and promoting fair
trade and investment practices the
economy is important but above all it is
crucial that we stand behind our values
thank you
thank you very much as next is Mr Edna
de Paseo please the floor is yours
president
High representative colleagues
it should be simple easy to have a
coherent strategy for EU China relations
because we want to have strategic
autonomy whatever that means
and we have strategic autonomy and we're
not led by our partners
or arrivals so we have to diversify our
trading partners so that we're not
victims of coercion and that was a hard
lesson we've learned from Russia the
second lesson is that the EU can never
and should never be neutral it must
speak with one voice if there is
threat of a war or a war and we need to
react appropriately if we are going to
act appropriately we have to learn
lessons but we haven't learned those
lessons yet for me it's clear the
straight status quo in these Strait of
Taiwan cannot be changed all of this is
part of a coherent strategy vis-a-vis
China and we all need to stick to that
there can't be any uh national interests
that come to the foreign
colleagues
I'm from Hamburg and our wonderful
Port has become the most recent symbol
of dependence on China a Container
Terminal in Chinese hands doesn't sound
relevant unless you think about all the
puzzle pieces other than this one
there's Rotterdam there's 14 other ports
and when we put all these puzzle pieces
together then we see systemic
competition in all political areas so
we're at the beginning of an age of AI
with so many opportunities for our
society at the same time we have to be
take a warning from the Chinese
surveillance state that that's not the
direction we want to go we cannot be
dependent on technology made in China
because
the economic dependence on China is a
specialty and when autocracies insist on
the rule of the strongest and they want
we our offer has to be more cooperation
among equals more free trade with
Partners in order to ensure peace and
freedom and democracy these are values
that we have to bring forward in an
alliance of democracies an alliance that
stands up to the auto autocrats of this
world
thank you very much
Mr Paolo grangel has the floor
president High representative
vice president
[Music]
Portugal Chinese relations
go back so long in history the longest
of any two Nations we know how important
it is to have dialogue and trade with
China
but
their untrammeled friendship
with you with Russia their treatment of
the uyghurs
there
actions vis-a-vis Taiwan all need to be
talked about
and
we need to back president vonderlein not
President macron we need strategic
autonomy for Europe
and our strategic rival our systemic
rival is not the us our systemic rival
is China
so autonomy is not a third way
Europe will only be truly
strategically autonomous if we
are one that looks across the pond and
one that cultivates ties
with the US
that's why we need to have a Firm Stance
vis-a-vis China we need to defend
International order and we need to
defend Taiwan and human rights
thank you very much
what's next is Mrs Margarita Marcus
please the floor is yours
president
thank you very much president
commissioner High representative
the EU China strategy needs to be
defined at inter-institutional level one
single institution on its own cannot
come up with the eu's position vis-a-vis
China and that's why we're having this
debate
the EU is a global Powerhouse and it has
to come up with its own priorities and
its own way forward in its dialogue with
China That's why since the Lisbon treaty
we've had the high representative for
foreign affairs for external matters we
know that last year there were new
turbulences in our bilateral
relationship with China we know that
China represents
challenges and opportunities but these
have changed over time we have red lines
the respect for human rights is one of
those but China is an important partner
in terms of the global balance
at the end of the day we need to have a
political economic and security-based
strategy that will benefit the EU which
will ensure our
strategic autonomy and which will
contribute to peace and multilateralism
thank you
thank you very much
the president Dear Mr Burrell dear vice
president of the European commission
colleagues this debate is certainly not
about two things this debate is not
about playing the the blaming game and
this is not about choosing sites because
we know our sides
when all our partners we know our
friends and we are working together with
them but this is the better certainly
about the topic the need for coherent
strategy for EU China relationship and
we need the strategy uh Mr Burrell and
this was uh strongly uh suggested to you
by by many by many colleagues before me
I do agree with those saying that the EU
China relationship is of strategic
importance but we should be clear that
China poses a challenge to the liberal
order of today the country is a global
Powerhouse and we need to address the
challenges uh at stake together
first and foremost you must prioritize
its Security's interests in its
relationship with China we need to
carefully assess the implications of
Chinese military activities uh in in
Taiwan but also to talk uh boldly about
human rights what China is doing in
xinjiang region with eagles is
completely unacceptable and I want to
State this clearly from this house thank
you
thank you very much
China looks at Europe and seeds division
we must show unity and strength as
president Wonderland is cautioned we
must clearly set the terms of a healthy
engagement we must be honest and clear
and recognize that China certainly does
not play by our rules and yet China is a
vital trading partner but it seeks to
dominate vital Supply chains their acts
are not in line with our European values
human rights abuses of the uyghurs an
opaic stand on the Ukraine invasion
threatening freedom and democracy in
their own backyard we must play to our
strengths promote global trade and
engage as an equal we must take the lead
along with our partners in the
Democratic World in regulating critical
sectors such as AI to protect Global
standards and the protection of Rights
China's interactions with Putin are a
cause of absolutely serious concern
I need support in the form of weapons or
otherwise would be hugely detrimental to
our future relations we should not allow
ourselves to be divided thank you
thank you very much
what's next
is Mr Niels looks like please the floor
is yours
means
well China in recent years has become
more autocratic we in Europe has become
more dependent on China
and you can see how significant it is
with raw materials coming from China for
our Industries and how our critical
infrastructure ends up in Chinese hands
here for example China's purchasing of
Greece's largest port Perez and China's
new uh plans to buy a part of the
Hamburg Port so enough should be enough
so I have two proposals first of all in
the EU we should adopt a common
definition of critical infrastructure
and promise one another that we are not
selling that to foreign powers and then
secondly we have to look at the crucial
Industries the for example mining or the
production within the green sector we
have it's time that the EU has a more
critical attitude towards China we have
to stand up for our values and see that
freedom depends on Independence
thank you very much as next Mr stefanet
as the floor please the floor is yours
dear colleagues there is a clear
learning from current International
Development and that is that democracies
should stand together and this learning
is even more applicable towards China
's growth means really an economic
opportunity but China's growth means
also a serious threat in terms of
military in terms of critical raw
material in terms of its growing
influence in international organizations
what to do the answer is definitely the
European Unity towards China's expansion
and our close cooperation with U.S the
most important European actions should
be firstly to protect Taiwan secondly to
strengthen and modernize our defense
capacities particularly in terms of
cyber security and thirdly to secure our
supply chain of critical raw materials
ladies and gentlemen world is changing
and we are able to shape it only based
on our European Unity
our cooperation among democracies and
our position towards autocracies thank
you indeed
thank you very much what's next
Mr Marcos Ross semper please de floresio
commissioner High representative
what have we learned during this time in
office
we cannot forget
the saddest most difficult times during
the pandemic when we were dependent on
China for PPE and we see it now with the
energy crisis we're going through
China is stockpiling
Fuel and we meanwhile are fighting for
energy Independence in Europe the EU
must step up and become a true
geopolitical power that means becoming
less dependent technologically speaking
and in terms of production on other
countries we must learn the tough
lessons from this term in office
we've got it in us to be strategically
autonomous it doesn't mean cutting ties
with China in trade terms it means
rebalancing them
every member state
mustn't work on its own but we must work
together with one voice in a coordinated
fashion as Mr Burrell said above all we
need to be aware of the fact that the EU
is a and must be a world reference point
for democracy and for the respect of
Human Rights thank you
thank you very much
what's next Mr Pedro Van Damme has the
floor place the force you
drink
president
in China many Christians and other
religions are persecuted the weakers
disappear into camps
um there's illegal
use of human organs
um China just goes for raw materials no
matter where they are and China Imports
oil from Russia so this is reason enough
for European boycott against China but
unfortunately this is not feasible
because in this house there are more
followers of the merchants than the
ministers in a church
um
and therefore we must try to tackle
things in a different way
we have to think in terms of
uh
strengthening uh the European consumers
confidence in the value of European
products and the consumers must be
encouraged not to buy Chinese products
we must insist that they not buy a
Chinese products because that way Europe
will be able to enhance its autonomy
will we we will be less dependent on
China and we will be having our own
producers so that's strengthen each
other's economy by of buying European
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker Mr
America
president
this week the parliament is going to
make very important decisions on the
climate the threat to the climate is
global the EU China they are dependent
upon one another in order to meet this
climate threat
we are dependent on trade and
cooperation in order to produce
important thing some like wind turbines
and solar solar panels if we're going to
meet this climate challenge then we have
to develop our Corporation at the same
time we're much too dependent on China
especially with access to critical raw
Earths where we have to find more other
partners more stable Partners so if we
talk about climate China has to be
included in the work however when we do
that we have to strengthen our demands
and insist on their improving human
rights better labor conditions and the
rights of the regions to have
Independence thank you
Mr President opening statement of higher
representative and commission president
some upwell where is our relationship
with China it's not easy listening and
nice one we have unbalanced economic
relationship we are depending on China
raw materials Technologies and the
products there are concerns about
security especially in the case of
Taiwan and in the world of global
politics especially after Russian attack
on Ukraine we know that China is not
playing on our favor
uh to correct to correct current this
equilibrium that was built over the
decades by wrong policies we need to act
now and anyway it will take many years
to change it
to do it we need a consistent clear and
transparent EU policy that is not
undermined by short-term interest of
some member states I hope this debate
will help us to get to that soon as we
badly need it thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
Gabriel Mata you have the floor
president a coherent strategy for EU
China
that is something we need but we also
need to be realist we need to have
mutual trust and we need to have
transparency
no one is denying that ties with China
on com are complex but it is a necessary
partner if we are to deal with global
challenges it's a strong economic
partner but it must do that in line with
WTO rules and it is also a strategic and
systemic rival thus the EU must have a
medium and long-term strategy for China
that takes everything I've said on board
with clear objectives which complement
each other and which are in line with
our
partners and like-minded allies and we
also need to have control mechanisms
the eu's leaders must work hand in hand
and in unison
only if we work together will the 27
move forward and have a stronger role in
the world
and we need to look at what China is
doing vis-a-vis Russia China needs to
show that he's on the right side of
history there vis-a-vis Russia
thank you very much I do apologize to
colleagues who have requested to catch
the eye we have to skip that because of
because of us running late so I'll now
give the floor to the Executive Vice
President of the commission Mr Valdez
domrovskis
Mr chair honorable representative Madam
Minister honorable members
I would like to thank you for this which
Andrew we would debate it shows how
timely it is
today's debate clearly attests that EU
China relationship must be seen in an
increasingly complex geopolitical
context
uh several speakers straight stress
China's ambiguous position on Russia's
war of aggression against Ukraine it
hurts EU China relations just as Europe
is deeply hurt by the war on its
continent
on Taiwan the EU remains strongly
opposed to any unilateral change of
status quo in Taiwan Strait especially
by use of force
its preservation has been uh uh uh a way
for a peaceful development economic
growth and prosperity in the region
it is key to exercise restraint tension
should be resolved through a meaningful
and open dialogue the EU will continue
its efforts aiming to preserve peace and
stability in the region
yet despite the worsening a political
context the EU China trade remains
robust
total Goods trade between the EU and
China reached the total of
856 billion euros in 2022 it means 2.3
billion euros of trade every day
however while overall beneficial the EU
China economic relationship remains
critically unbalanced
uh for instance in 2022 the eu's
bilateral trade deficit with China
reached an unprecedented level
396 billion euros
as president vonderlein said there is an
urgent need to rebalance our
relationship we should seek more
transparency predictability and
reciprocity
to achieve this goal engagement with
China will be key including on trade
returns
the high level dialogues on economy and
trade on environment and climate and on
digital are valuable platforms for the
engagement
it is of course important that they
produce concrete results it is a matter
of credibility
finally as a president emphasized today
the central part of our future China
strategy must be economic risking
going forward the eu's objective is to
avoid over dependencies on China for
example the EU should not only depend on
China for critical raw materials that
are essential for the green and digital
transition
it means diversifying sources of EU
supplies and this is very different from
economic decoupling
uh the commissioner will pull forward a
New Economic Security strategy in the
coming months so
honorable members to conclude I fully
agree with this house to succeed our
relationship with China Europe must show
a United stance
so I would like to thank honorable
members of this Parliament for
re-emphasizing this major point today
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and for the
conclusion
Mr
Joseph Burrell has the floor
is
president
ladies and gentlemen
Emmy pays
I'll continue to speak Spanish
as former president of the European
Parliament
it's
so pleasing to me to see the European
Parliament back to the rafters this
hemicycle pact to the rafters
so I'm glad to see so many people
ladies and gentlemen
I have listened to the debate and many
were critical
about the so-called European cacophony
the fact that there is
there are various voices and not
everyone is saying the same thing or in
the same way
I think there are two reasons which
explain why this has happened
the fact is simply that there are
different points of view
between the member states as regards
China
this ought not to be a surprise to
anyone
that's the way it is
the aim of a common policy is to
smooth out these differences and find a
common denominator in order to do that
you have to work together though
then there's a second reason
which has led to what many MEPS have
criticized indeed there have been some
failings to coordinate between the EU
institutions and the member states
these could have been avoided
I think we need to note what's happened
be self-critical and come up with
Solutions in the future that will be
based on greater coordination between
the institutions and between the states
so between the institutions I.E between
commission and Council between the
member states themselves and then
between the member states and the
institutions a lot of criticism was also
leveled against President macron
I
perused
his
speech in the Nexus Institute in The
Hague
where he spoke and further developed his
view of strategic autonomy
I think many of his ideas were very
positive and pro-european and I
completely backed them and I think we
can need to continue to work on a
concept
that isn't contradictory with our
Atlantic Alliance
something that isn't about
finding alternatives to our partnership
with the US no it's not about
an alternative to Nato
quite the contrary
it's about making our transatlantic ties
even stronger
and they will be stronger if we
ourselves are stronger
the US
and NATO
cannot be responsible for solving all of
the crises that have Fallout for Europe
we have to develop our own capacity
as I said earlier reducing risk it is
also tantamount to improving our
autonomy
so risk and autonomy
are in contradiction to each other so if
we reduce our risk we can become more
strategically autonomous there are
political and economic risks
alliances are only stable and deserve
that name if they are balanced if they
are unbalanced
then they're not true alliances they're
another kind of relationship
we as Europeans need to be strong so
that our transatlantic partnership can
be stronger
we also need to talk about Economic
Security
but Economic Security is also closely
linked to security I say Economic
Security but it boils down to security
an integral part
and it's an integral part of external
affairs
I'm glad that the commission wants to
work on this and work in this area but
it cannot do this alone it depends on
the member states too namely the council
and we're going to prevent further
cacophony we are going to work together
we're going to have an economic
security framework and a security
framework
let's not focus on the adjective but on
the noun we have to come up with a new
way to tackle security issues and here
the parliament needs to play a key role
because we're talking about a highly
political matter a matter that affects
our democracy and Europe's place in the
world thank you very much
thank you very much that concludes the
debates and we'll resume shortly with
the vote
foreign
good afternoon dear colleagues